it's dark 24 000 feet on k2 in winter
and there there's 10 people now outside
with no tents oh my god
so a guy pops his head into my tent and
he's like hey man like we're out here
like we have no tents like can we come
inside and before i know it there's
seven people inside of my tent this is a
bad situation like people are gonna die
out here i think people are gonna die
out here i'm saying this is a bad like a
bad deal
hey everybody welcome to the podcast my
guest today returning for his fifth
appearance on the show if you can
believe it is adventure athlete colin
o'brady and he's joined
by his wife and partner in all things
jennifer saw who is appearing for the
first time on the show
long time listeners are well acquainted
with colin's very long list of
accomplishments as a 10 time world
record-breaking explorer a new york
times best-selling author and an expert
on mindset high performance and
empowering others to
reimagine the limits of human
possibility colin's feats include the
world's first solo unsupported and fully
human-powered crossing of antarctica he
sets speed records for the explorers
grand slam and the seven summits and the
first human-powered ocean row across
drake passage colin's latest book is
entitled the 12-hour walk which is based
on this idea that colin had during the
2020 coveted lockdown when everything
stopped and
like a lot of us he found himself
lacking purpose lacking direction and on
kind of a whim he decided to just go out
on a walk no phone no direction no
destination in mind and ended up
returning 12 hours later a different
person and really inspired by that
experience to
invite others to experience what he had
as a means of personal empowerment
so today we talk about that of course
including his 12-hour walk movement
which invites all of us to join him on
september 10 to do our own 12-hour walk
which you can learn more about at
12hourwalk.com
we also discuss colin and jenna's most
recent expedition to everest with friend
of the podcast mike posner in addition
we cover colin's absolutely harrowing
experience on k2
and most importantly jenna's role and
her perspective in all of it because
none of colin's feats would have come to
pass without jenna she's just the engine
behind everything they have accomplished
together which is why i'm so excited to
introduce her to all of you today in
addition to just incredible stories
throughout this conversation you're
going to find actionable insights on
tackling limiting beliefs on adopting
what colin and jenna call
the possible mindset you're going to
learn about reframing the limits of your
own potential and just tons more so
without further ado please hit that
subscribe button and enjoy
well it's great to see you guys i'm
really happy to do this with you and and
jenna is here today i can't wait to talk
to jenna
uh who said no to the today show how
many times refuses to be interviewed
but you're going to talk today because
i've heard enough of this dude over here
he's been on the podcast too many times
so it's going to be all about jenna
today oh god jenna's got the best story
so that's perfect
we'll riff and have some fun yeah i mean
let's start with that i mean what is it
i'm interested in you know we've all
heard about
colin's adventures there's too many to
even keep track of all these world
records and death defying and you know
expeditions etc but you're the engine
behind the whole thing right you're the
one who keeps it on track
who's doing the boring kind of
unheralded uh hero work and i'm just
curious about like how you keep it all
together and and what the mechanics of
all of that are about for you because it
doesn't happen without i mean colin's
always saying like it's jenna it's jenna
i can't do this without jenna
but you know we've never heard from you
yeah well i really appreciate being here
thanks for inviting me it's great to see
you and having a conversation um
you know it it started so long ago colin
and i have been together in a
relationship for a long time and then
business has kind of just organically
evolved for us in partnership and
um for me it's it's really this
beautiful kind of song and dance that we
get to share where colin is pursuing
some of his greatest passions and i get
to be in full support but in full
creator mode with him so it's not just
me i'm standing behind the scenes
helping him create what he wants to it's
really kind of a choreographed dance if
you will where we get to show our
strengths and kind of participate in
creating together right and what happens
when you get those sat calls and you
know he's in paris
not a second
right
um
yeah man it's been
i mean it's been a learning process
right like we've we've grown up together
and we have experienced a lot together
both super high highs and and some
pretty dark
intense expedition moments and
um
you know the the sat phone calls i
always answer with
an open heart but the biggest amount of
trepidation right because i never know
if it's going to be all's well we're
we're doing great or if it's going to be
a tragic jenna has jenna has definitely
walked me off some cliffs out there um
you know on the edge you know
one one that comes to mind i remember
calling you um from antarctica somewhere
around day 40 of solo crossing jenna
there was two people i talked to on the
antarctic are crossing by the way on the
stat phone well i guess if we count paul
simon paul simon was one but there was
jenna i had my nightly check-in from
there and also adam skolnick oh that's
right
skullnick his tentacles
everywhere i know i've i completely
forgot about that because he was doing
crazy reporting on that i mean there's
new york times pieces there was epic i
think there was eight new york times
pieces that he shot and jenna was
running that pr i mean adam has such a
special place in my heart he talked
about me being collins rock like adam
was my rock during that whole thing i
mean he i talked to him every day
multiple times a day just because he was
reporting on it but he he just became
such a close friend yeah
he definitely always it was interesting
he does such a good job of the integrity
of a journalist like hey i'm a
journalist and i'm reporting the facts
this is journalism but also he's like i
also understand that like you're not
talking to anyone like jenna's not
talking like the two of them only people
talking to me during that crossing so
it's a very unique sort of position um
and like i mean i mean i think i only
talked to him two times or something to
give interviews but you guys were kind
of i was relaying a lot of information
to him because i would talk to colin in
really brief snippets right those
crackly satellite phone calls so it's
not like oh we're just having this
really easy you know mellow chill
conversation but in that i would have to
distill down some some pieces to send
over to adam so that you could
accurately report on the crossing yeah
but i think to me like what i was
thinking of is there's there's so many
moments but one that really comes to
mind that combines i think a lot of
things was
i get to the south pole on day 40 on
that crossing and jen i have this great
i kind of have this euphoric you you
know you thought i was on drugs you see
like you know dopamine rush of like oh
my god i'm here it's beautiful it's
sunny it's all the stuff and like jenna
can hear it in my voice she kind of lets
me be in la la land by myself like for
that day before she drops the bomb and
then the next day
she says hey we gotta talk for real
and i couldn't in that moment i had such
a huge piece of information to share
with him that i really needed him to
execute on but he was just in such a
blissful place which wasn't always the
case of course right he had a lot of
down down days and down moments and i
was just like i can't drop this on him
yet so let him enjoy it one day won't
crush when i have about to tell him so
and i remember never forget she's like
so now we need to talk for real and
she's like
you don't have enough i'm running the
spreadsheet so jenna's not only dreaming
up these projects together she's
building them together we're in the
weeds that's why i say it's it's a shame
it's my name on the world records
because it is both of ours completely
from you know origin all the way through
execution let's be clear i did not walk
across antarctica
i don't know
in a vacuum but for you to be not just
my wife the love of my life we've been
you know together for 15 years it's been
an incredible journey but then for you
to actually have to say hey colin you do
not have enough food in your sled you do
not have enough calories in your sled i
know you're starving out there i've been
telling you my hips are sticking out my
ribs are sticking out i'm exhausted he
told me he had to take out a sewing kit
and stitch in every few days a little
less fabric because it was his his pants
were falling down essentially so i'm
like running this in my mind while also
looking at the spreadsheets and i'm like
oh no this calories are running this
isn't and you know that i'm burning ten
thousand i'm eating seven thousand and
you call me and you say
there's no way you're going to finish
this unless you go down to roughly five
thousand and i don't know i mean that's
always interesting i'm curious
that now richard are both interviewing
you so yeah but is that also part of the
i mean the new book which we're gonna
get into kind of opens with this story
about how you have to tell him he can't
you're doing 10 hour days in antarctica
yeah and you have this moment where you
feel like you can't push any further or
harder and your neck and neck with rudd
um and jenna you're like you're gonna
have to do
extra hours it was that part of the
calorie conversation or was that
something different he had already
started to do the extra hours by this
point by this time yeah if you take it
back oh yeah if you take it back to the
very beginning i mean
to colin's credit he definitely went out
there thinking i think i can do this
crossing but i would say you didn't have
like the best plan like he really didn't
not just very under the best babe but
like
colin's fan was like yeah i'm gonna go
out there and i'm gonna walk like about
10 hours a day and we're just going to
like see how it goes and i was like
that's the plan like that's the plan
and pretty quickly we needed to come up
with an actual like legitimate
spreadsheetable plan that could
calculate not only hours and miles
walked but calories right calories were
the the linchpin in this whole thing
um
obviously of course it came down to the
sled that he was pulling how much weight
was in it what how many calories she was
burning like all of all the pieces that
went into this calculation and so um
i mean it it was a nightmare to begin
with really when column was like uh
i have to walk further and longer each
day in order to make this happen
and
you're gonna run out of calories i mean
we figured it out pretty quickly but but
i was definitely in that moment for sure
in that moment particularly
as i'm getting my butt kicked by rudd in
the first week i'm calling jenna i'm
crying i'm calling jenna i can't do this
i mean every limiting belief is in my
mind i can't pull my sled it's not going
to work i can't go far enough i'm
getting my butt kicked i told the press
that i'm going to do this big thing and
it's going to be an epic failure and he
was
in a rough spot the first week yeah i
mean not only with the food we're
talking about on day 40 we take probably
back to day five of that and we write
about this in the new book the 12-hour
walk of you being like
you're trying to help me problem-solve
like you've been i've you know i've said
this to you of course not on a podcast
but i'll say it again now which is to me
your the balance of the strength that
you've shown the love that you've shown
me has certainly got me to the finish
line but also the poise like how hard it
would be in those moments to just be
like okay it's too hard whatever like
you are you're
you're asking me and you're telling me
like well can you go a little bit
further can't i'm saying i can't go any
further
his responses were not delicate let me
tell you that i have to be a
psychologist too like when's the right
moment to tell him he's gonna have to go
further on less calories each day right
yeah and then it's admin and then it's
interesting thing right because you're
saying this too it's not i guess the one
thing it was like your business partner
or like your coach or something like
this but like
totally i mean this is my husband the
person that i care and love the most in
the world right and i'm having to
find his edge press on it see how he
reacts and responds assess that make
minor detail you know little adjustments
along the way and hope hope and pray
that it's all going to work out right
right
and if it doesn't
the stakes are high really high yeah
yeah yeah and meanwhile behind the
scenes just i want to get a you know
glean a sense of like the scale
of what's required to pull something
like this off like my only frame of
reference was doing epic five which is
like nothing compared to the scale of
the expeditions that you're doing
and and in that case like jason did
almost all of it like i just showed up
for the ride with that
um but in this case it requires a lot of
money in intense pre
like pre-pre it's like making a movie
like you have pre-production and you got
to make these spreadsheets and you got
to figure out what's going to be on the
sled it can't be too heavy it can't be
too light how are we going to make sure
there's enough calories how are we going
to make sure that he has backup gear if
stuff goes wrong because stuff always
goes wrong like who's paying for this
how is this all coming together like i
think like it's
you know it's like without a team of
like 12 people working you know around
the clock
no and we've really always kind of been
a lean and mean
team to me the moment that i come back
to always around this um is in 2014 so i
was racing triathlon professionally at
the time jenna had come out on the road
with me full-time for a couple years was
kind of starting to step into
management think about helping sponsored
whatever it was it was peanut butter and
jelly sandwiches and sleeping on
people's floors like this wasn't
glamorous in fact jenna was like i need
to have a real career and i was like no
let's do the itu circuit
maybe i should get a real job and help
support you're like colin that is not my
everest yeah exactly like this she's
like i'd be like it's cool that you're
into this or whatever but it was
beautiful in the fact that you've always
been adventurous so we're like well at
least we can go to all these countries
and again like we had no money so we
were basically home stays people you
know basically opening their homes to us
letting them sleep giving us food
it's a grind yeah it's a major grind
yeah yeah and so we lived that and then
we in the
we were racing it in south america in
the fall of 2014
we
went to climb ecuador's three volcanoes
there's there's a bunch of volcanoes
there but there's three the three
tallest ones cayon bay cotopaxi and
chimborazo and i had always like loved
climbing some mountains but jenna had
done a little bit of that but not much i
wanted to be very i like i am not an
expedition oriented person like i grew
up single mom only child like she did
not take me camping this is not
something that i was like at all privy
to until i met you play sports in high
school and stuff i did but like you know
tennis and i was a skier and i mostly
was a ballet dancer and so that was i
mean i wasn't really
i mean i guess tennis you would consider
team sport because there was a team of
us but i was a singles player you know
like i wasn't in teams you're not like a
like a a thrill-seeking snowboarding
rock climbing type of place and when i
met jenna i met jenna when we were 20
she was 20 and she was in college at
that point you weren't playing sports
anymore i mean it was like a part of
your childhood song
but we were so i said let's go climb
these mountains in ecuador and holman
drew this in the off season so this was
colin's like vacation away from sports
was to go out and climb these massive
mountains and i was like okay what world
is this a vacation but like okay i'm in
but the year before it the year before
they end it with a with a nice hotel
right unfortunately we couldn't afford
much of a nice hotel at that point
either
but we we go there because the year
before we i've been racing in africa we
have been together um racing in africa
on zimbabwe and we went and climbed
kilimanjaro together and you climbed
kilimanjaro and you're like wow that was
cool so we said next year let's do
something else like this
and
you know
us how old were we at this point i was
20 or 26 27 i was 30 maybe 29 something
like that um yeah under 29.29 brought a
diamond ring up there in my pocket
somewhat of the kyambi this beautiful
sunny day asked jenna to marry me and
we're on the summit of this beautiful
glaciated peak 19 almost 19 000 feet in
ecuador mountain called cayme
we had this moment that again at the
time i didn't obviously i thought
getting engaged would be a really
special moment but i didn't necessarily
know this would be such a ripple effect
moment throughout our life which comes
back to how do we have the money to do
this how do we figure this out all this
kind of stuff which was
we sat there on this mountaintop
and we just looked at each other and
this kind of blissed out like oh my god
we're going to get married i love you so
much moment but just like
what do we want to do with our life like
just have it like just like an in the
moment brainstorm of like let's dream
without limits and in the new book the
12-hour walk one of the framing
principles literally the first page is
something that i define i called a
possible mindset which i define
dictionary definition learn the front to
my own dictionary definition right which
says an empowered way of thinking that
unlocks a life of limitless
possibilities and so on this mountaintop
is we're getting engaged we look at each
other and kind of do this you know just
on the fly exercise of like if there
were no limits if money wasn't an issue
if we had the resources we had the
network if we had this that the other
thing like what would we want to do
in this moment let's dream without
limits and i remember that conversation
so vividly and maybe it was uh because
we were surrounded by mountains or or
whatnot but we dreamed up uh what became
our first you know collective world
record project which was the explorer's
grand slam i said my childhood dream has
always been to climb mount everest we
started riffing on
things that included everest which was
like the seven summits world record it
explores grand slam the seven summits
plus north and south pole
and then both of us said
the triathlon lifestyle although we
loved it
mostly there was things we didn't like
about it but was
it was lacking an impact it was lacking
and having
sort of legs beyond it felt very
self-serving right you show up at a you
fly to this race you've trained for this
race you fly to this race you show up
you race
it's over you sponsors maybe you're
happy or not
yeah if you're gonna make the olympic
team then it's one thing yeah like if
that's your you know apex mountain for
that but short of that you know it just
becomes like this washing machine
lifestyle you know look i love it i mean
i respected all my friends and i mean
that community obviously was trying to
make the olympics i came up short great
friends of mine made that next olympics
joe malloy who's a dear friend of both
jen and i we travel the world with gary
i mean it's amazing guy those guys in
the olympics that you're dear friends we
train with them a ton but there was a a
limit to that and so in this mountain
that same mountain we said like let's
start this maybe we can like have impact
millions of kids with non-profit or
something like that and it's funny to
look at that moment now because like we
on that mountaintop had no we had no
money literally no money we had no
background no idea how to start a
nonprofit knew nothing of press or media
or pr or digital scale or social was
somewhat new-ish at the time in the way
that we think about it now
um
but that possible mindset that limitless
possibility has allowed us in this naive
moment of being engaged yeah to dream
right absolutely all right but like real
talk yeah
are you sure jenna that colin didn't
bully you into this because it sounds
like this is his dream
right like where do you like what's your
you know
because this isn't bred into your dna in
the way that it is for colin yeah no i
mean everest certainly was not a
childhood dream of mine i mean literally
not even close i don't think i'd read
anything about it other than i knew that
was tallest mountain in the world like
that was it um and so the
the
the challenge to climb the mountains
wasn't my interest right i mean i was
like cool you want to do that great at
least you want to do that because that's
your thing um but for me it really was
about the impact right we we kind of you
know started batting ideas around like
what's important to us and kids have
always been really important to me um i
just think they're you know the the next
generation there really is who's gonna
take the reins from us as we continue to
build this world and
there just seemed like you know a great
combination of colin's love of sports
and my interest in impact and how could
we do that in a sustainable way that
felt like uh something that had you know
legs that we could talk about in the
world that was interesting i'll also say
that's a hundred i love the greatest
such a good question because it's fair
it's totally fair by like let's climb
these mountains like that's clearly me
driving that yeah but i think that what
was interesting during the time when
jenna was observing the triathlon
world the scene from helping me with
sponsors which was like by the way like
a free bike helmet here or there a pair
of sunglasses it wasn't like
yeah was it um
she kept being like
and again it's funny because now i think
of you as such an amazing marketer such
a talented pr person but at that time
you didn't have that but you had these
instincts like you kept looking at like
you were like i don't understand why
that guy
isn't having more impact or this
person's not reaching more people or
that wow like we'd be you know sitting
on the other side of the world with and
hear stories from these athletes and i'd
be like why does no one know that story
like someone should know that story that
makes you so much more interesting than
you can just swim back and run right
there were beautiful stories of people
out there that i was like oh this is
what people need to know about these
people so you had this like and i was
and jenna has one of the strongest
intuitions of anyone i've ever met but
you certainly had this it's so funny
looking back now you've built these very
successful media campaigns billions of
media impressions whatever through like
just your hard work and diligence and
figuring it out you haven't done any of
that time but you're looking at this
you're going there's something in these
stories there's something in the way to
like transmute this into impact like you
felt that thing in the ether yeah it was
it was i wouldn't say it was a calling
but it felt very organic for me
i just oh i get this i feel this i can
help help relay it right right right
right that first project was a a canvas
to paint on and make also i mean we
continue to make mistakes but certainly
in the early days of like so how do you
actually get sponsors
i mean i literally didn't know what the
difference between marketing and pr was
at that time like i'm like i don't know
what the difference between
i mean they go hand in hand there's a
difference i don't you know they go hand
in hand but like truly i was like
google what is the difference between
marketing and pr and how how do we do
this how do we tell the story how do we
reach people
and kind of just and when you're putting
these expeditions together like what is
the value proposition for the person
that you're trying to get money from
right like is it a brand awareness thing
or is it the impact that they can be
involved with
because like i said earlier like these
things cost a lot of money together
you're asking people to like hey we need
like dollar x
which is a high you know high dollar
item no i mean it's a perfect question
so the again
not trying to shamelessly plug the new
book but it really does bring up with
the book is framed around limited tell
me the title again the book is called
12-hour watch okay but no
it's framed or i love it i love it we
have by the way paul knows the
difference between marketing and apr
all right go ahead rich and i have
training
the same editor 10 year anniversary of
finding old trucks congratulations by
the way man that's amazing and rick rick
horgan shout out to rick corgan who
edited my previous book and this book
and reached her first job on my book i
love rick rick's rich brick is uh rick
is quite a guy the smartest people i've
ever met quite literally he knows every
word literally
every email he's like just comes up with
new words i'm like i haven't looked at
his words
yeah he's a genius um but he's done
right by you and i that's for sure um
but no the the book is framed around
commonly limiting beliefs we all have
you know ten common and lemon beliefs
each one i break down a story from
adventure a genomized life um and then
speak directly to the reader about how
we can overcome these limiting beliefs
and we'll get to the larger call to
action there but one of the most common
limiting beliefs and that's why we're
talking about this right now it's not
why you brought it up but i pulled my
instagram audience and said a couple
years ago like what is stopping you from
living your best life what what is i
just want to know like what were people
thinking about and i thought i might get
hundreds of different responses but it
turned out that i got like the five same
responses hundreds of times and really
75 of them were i don't have enough
money if i had x amount of dollars i
would be doing this but i'm not
because i don't have that money and it
was the exact same problem that jenna
and i had sitting on the mountaintop
dreaming about this was like well
explores grand slam quick google you can
figure out going north pole south pole
everest whatever like you're looking
you're running a tally of half a million
dollars pretty quickly like it's and
that's not making any money that's just
like it's covered that's covering costs
like just purely covering costs
um
and it would have been super easy to let
us stop i mean i think that that's the
moment where like you have a good
business idea right you're hanging out
with your buddy at the bar hey we're
going to do an ironman triathlon we're
going to race a marathon you're having a
beer with your buddy on a sunday and
saturday night you wake up on monday
morning and you call your buddy and
you're like yeah like about that idea
yeah
you know like
like
yeah
we were just [ __ ] right um and i
think easily we could have got home from
that trip in ecuador you know the the
echo of the excitement of being engaged
as young people in 2014 um would have
worn off and been like okay but like so
like real jobs like what's your college
degree you know what are we gonna do um
but
i know you've talked about a lot on the
show rich i think there's a big
difference between belief and abundance
and the belief in scarcity right like
just that belief
um and i was actually listening to you
and skolnik chop it up on the 10-year
anniversary pod of finding ultra
you'll have to say say the line but you
said something like when you're living
in your truth the universe conspires
what's the what's the word when your
heart is true the universe will conspire
to support you i mean i think yeah to
kind of drill down to brass tacks on
that
what i hear in your story and i've
experienced this myself is
that
on some level you have to believe it's
possible and you don't have to
completely buy into that you can have
rational skepticism like wow that's
going to be really hard i don't i don't
know if i can do that but what can i do
right now i don't have any money but i
can go do this and i can i think the
more little kind of steps you take
in the direction of that thing that you
you know dream about or aspire to have
in your life
there is energy that kind of coalesces
around that and then the next step will
be reveal you're not i think a lot of
people just sit around and they want to
see how the path is going to unfold all
the way to the end or the destination
and it doesn't work that way like you
have to with each step you get a little
bit more confidence and you get a little
bit more evidence and you know i can't
like pick iron man like iron man's
expensive yeah so well i want to do an
iron man i don't have any money and i
don't own a bike but you know i borrowed
my friend's bike and i rode for a while
and then you know after doing that for
three or four months this other friend
of mine had an extra bike and he said
he'd sell it to me for like you know 20
of what it's worth and you just you kind
of make it work and then the more that
you do that the more the universe kind
of opens up to you and things happen and
that sounds perhaps a bit too ephemeral
or mystical and maybe even privileged
but i've seen it happen in my life this
is certainly the path that you guys have
have taken like totally things occur
when you just keep pushing forward
incrementally 100 and i think that it
comes also back to
you're gonna get like your buddy didn't
sell you the bike on the first time you
thought about having a bike that might
be like when you're thinking about how
to get a bike for three months and that
finally comes around meaning like you
didn't like give up on your dream to
have a bike after the first you got to
earn the dream totally i love that
diligence and
work ethic right
and the more that the more kind of sweat
equity you put into it
the you know the more opportunities
you're creating for yourself
and it doesn't it doesn't lay out
linearly or on the timeline that you
would prefer right
eventually the person you least expect
to open a door for you is the one who
does
and i i mean two two four one there's a
to me there's
amazing help me tell this story but
we we were six eight months into trying
to raise money for the explorers grand
slam project and had raised very little
a triathlon sponsor of mine had who a
guy high net worth guy named brian
gelber who would help me out first mars
i've said i'll help you once you show me
you can have some proper sponsors like
i'm not just gonna write you a check so
show me a nike sponsorship show me like
a real quote-unquote sponsorship and
then i can maybe you know help you guys
out so that was a big thing
only if we could prove ourselves
basically right but it's like here's a
little shred of hope like okay there's a
crack here like now i have something to
work with but then six eight months down
the road we still had raised basically
zero dollars and we finally by
you know friend of a friend of a friend
had introduced us to someone at columbia
sportswear who had introduced us up the
chain at columbia sports where after
five people said no we actually get a
meeting with tim boyle who's the ceo of
um columbia sportswear based in portland
um
and they also own mountain hardwear and
surreal and a bunch of the other like
you know whatever climbing brands and
we're like oh my god this is our big
shot like this is our big shot
we prepped for the meeting jen and i
were like did we like read
his mom's book about the starting of the
company we do all the things we like buy
their clothes to go to the office and of
course we couldn't afford
and we walk in
and
he sits down
and he looks at us the first thing you
see he's kind of like who are you guys
and you realize like we've been prepping
for this meeting and this is like two
minutes in between something actually
important that he's taking and we're
like oh shoot and we like we're ready
with this whole we're thinking he's
gonna give us the time of day to like do
the whole presentation
we're like we have this like website
with like a video on it and like
whatever and we like play it for him and
you can just see his eyes just kind of
like glaze over and he's like cool cool
like uh hey good luck with that like
good job you guys good luck with that
and we're like being ushered out the
door
and jenna is just
a complete savage
like i was like well
don't i was like i was like this can't
be it like this cannot be the end of the
road for this because you know in
looking through all the different
sponsorship opportunities i was you know
when you just can feel something is
right i'm like this is the one we cannot
let this slip through the cracks
and
i just pivoted and said like mr boyle
like colin here's a local guy from
portland you haven't even heard his
whole story give me five minutes to tell
you
what you need to know here and i just
truly from the heart like i and i am not
one to just like raise my hand and speak
up and like you know jump into the
middle of something and it just came out
so organically and so naturally i shared
exactly what we were trying to do
how much money we were trying to raise
and i think this was for the explorers
grand slams
never died literally
we had nothing and jenna
what she's being humble jenna is
generally a really a natural introvert
and
um
just uh i don't know you're not one to
just like you but in that moment to be
like actually excuse me mr boyle like he
was like what like i just thought it's
like who's this girl's 27 year old girl
sitting in the corner she's like excuse
me miss bro actually i think there's a
little more it's like to this like you
know high-powered ceo and she kind of
sits him back down in his chair
and just goes like goes in it's like
there's more here so i think it's a
combination of that belief in abundance
which is to even get that meeting it was
like no no no yes meet a guy at a coffee
shop who could introduce you to here
there and both of us like doing that but
also in the moment like you're in this
moment and you're like okay i could do
these inflection points where you know
you have to crush it yeah and they're
saying the guy's saying no he's
literally saying no and jenna's just
like i was even like i think both of us
really live by this quote a closed mouth
is never fed and it was like i hadn't
even had the chance to ask for what we
wanted before getting shut down and i
was like oh no this is the moment where
you have to speak up and you have to say
at least if you get to know you get to
know right right but it was a really
beautiful
um exchange and ultimately led to our
like first legitimate like real
sponsorship right so what is it what did
what did you say specifically that
turned the tide
it's a good question i mean it wasn't
recorded so i don't know exactly you
know specifically what i said but i
really i was like
colombia wants this and needs this like
i can see this for you guys as a brand
this is critical to what you're trying
to um use as a campaign and they were
doing tested tough tested tough yeah and
again this was years ago um and it's
just like everything that the project
was
sharing out in the world was exactly the
same talking points as this campaign um
and i think i just kind of you know
gave a little bit
from my standpoint she just she just
locked in it was just like i'm not
taking like he was just like whoa she's
not taking no for an answer okay well it
sounds to me like that about it
it was like a vibe shift from
hey you know we need this for us to
here's how we can fulfill your need
which is to extend your brand awareness
on this messaging that's completely on
point with what you're trying to do and
not for nothing you're not really doing
a very good job on it right now and in a
really unique way exactly like i was
like what we are bringing you're not
gonna get anywhere else like this is
colin can bring this uh we can bring
this as a team and like you want this
not in like a you know
crazy way but just in a very complete
honest way and i think he saw that i
think he finally saw the passion
and was willing to take a risk on us and
yeah i mean that that was a huge turning
point but it certainly was not it wasn't
going to pay for the balance of what we
were doing it was just to be like oh you
know you know a domino had fallen like
whoa columbia sports project that
allowed us sort of the ability to kind
of go out in the world but then
we were still a lot a lot of dollars
short you know of raising money for this
first project and um
you know basically just kept knocking on
doors and i think you know
my mom said this to me for a long time i
don't know if it's her quote i'm
probably not but she says you know luck
comes to those who are prepared um and
you know getting our first project off
the ground was two and the two of us
waking up every single day with our mind
flooded with doubt right like our mind
flooded with all these doubts like oh
this isn't going to work this isn't
going to this but then getting up and
doing it i mean i'll be curious for you
like
you're talking about you know being on
kauai starting the podcast like there
must have been all sorts of moments like
when you're like i'm doing this pocket a
pod what how do i even download that
like like it's that same moment like
what was that for you like when you're
like getting your thing like going well
the difference is like it was just a fun
creative thing like i didn't do it
because i was driving towards some
vision of what it could be it just felt
like a cool creative outlet that i
enjoyed and it organically built from
that and then at some point when it kind
of kicked in and i was like oh people
are really digging this like how can i
turn this into something more than what
it is currently and that's been a
journey of just
gradual iteration like there's there was
no big you know crazy spike or viral
moment it's just like showing up for it
every single day just like you're
training for a race like putting in the
hours and the miles
and yeah it's like we're in this amazing
studio but yeah it started in a
warehouse in kauai with a very humble
you know kind of approach to what we
were doing and it was really out of like
but my heart was true like i was doing
it for the joy of doing it not because
like oh i can i can turn this into like
a job and the consistency and the
passion and i think that it's
interesting when we reflect on our you
know our first project and that moment
with tim boyle jenna fully turned the
tides on even me who have been known to
be resilient and persistent like i was
like well i guess that's it like i was
ready to walk out of that room before
jenna really stepped in
um but
same for us like that was that first
project was born from can we just do
this can we like break even and just
have the like the honor of being able to
attempt this not like can we do this and
turn it into
a books and speaking and this it was
like literally can we do this and have
this non-profit that like helps some
people like just from that pure place of
the why and i think that the i mean i
talk about it in the 12-hour walk when i
talk about the money chapter which is
obviously something that's big big topic
for everyone myself included was like we
had this why
of wanting to do this and there was a
financial requirement for doing it
but the persistence the passion wasn't
like oh so let's raise this money so we
can quote unquote get rich or have like
a nicer car or a nicer thing it was like
we just want to do this to have the
impact the passion the perseverance the
the adventure the curiosity of doing
said thing
and i think i think in that moment in
that you know that tim boyle moment and
certainly there's so many other
inflection points in our life you know
where things have gone wrong we've
rewrited it whatever but
that passion that desire like the love
of the game like i just like wanting to
do this
our heart being true the way you said it
rich in your book i think it's it's part
and parcel of that
yeah i think there's this misplaced idea
uh you know
that uh you know people want to be like
they see you on stage at some ted event
or whatever and they're like i want to
be a public speaker
and they chase that but what they're
missing is you have to go out and do the
thing that lights you up to be you know
unique and interesting you have to go
live a certain type of life so that when
you get on a stage you have actually
something to say that has resonance
totally you know so it's a little bit
backwards i think
prophets walk among us
as a writer and podcaster for nearly 10
years i've become more convinced than
ever that our world is populated by
scores of beautiful and brilliant people
who have amazing stories to share
those that we don't know who can teach
us something new and leave us all the
better for the experience of their
sharing
and so i've dedicated my career to
tracking down the most compelling
profits on the planet going deep with
each of them on my podcast to elucidate
the best of what they have to offer and
to sharing the insights gleaned for the
benefit of all
but the podcast is not the only medium
by which to share their stories which is
why i'm proud to announce the release of
my new book
voicing change volume 2.
more than mere words on paper voicing
change is a physical manifestation of
the magic
inspiration
and timeless wisdom that transpires each
week on the ritual podcast
the first edition of voicing change was
a beautifully rendered book worthy of
display on any coffee table
and volume 2 follows in that tradition
by showcasing even more of my favorite
conversations in an elegant publication
replete with interview excerpts essays
and stunning photography making for an
exquisite companion to the first volume
or a satisfying stand-alone work
picking up this book allows you to
revisit the wisdom of your favorite
everyday prophets
and physically interact with the
life-changing ideas contained within
voicing change volume 2 available now
while supplies last for a limited time
order your copy today only at
richroll.com
so you go on and you do all of the i
mean we've you've been how many times
you've been on the show like four times
or something like that we've gone
through like you know like
nitty-gritty
expeditions you know like well you
reached out to me you're like hey i want
to come back i was like bro you've been
on so many times okay i got you got a
book like what else are we going to talk
about but like you're the full concept
though it's like jenna's gotta come
um
but uh so we don't need to like anybody
who's enjoying this can go back and
there's plenty of conversations you know
around the antarctica expedition the
seven summits etc and i encourage
everybody to go check those out we'll
put links in the show notes
um but let's let's kind of uh
get to
the new book which i think is really
interesting uh in that um
it provides you this opportunity to
share
lessons that you've learned from these
various expeditions but to do it in a
cons in a context where there's some
actionable takeaways from people and
it's all wrapped around this idea of of
the 12-hour walk so explain how you had
this kind of epiphany around
this experience that you could share and
create community around totally yeah no
um it is really exciting for me and
we'll get into what the details of it
are but it's fun to now have written
this book and have it be coming out
that's really at its core a call to
action for people to get involved not to
observe me doing an expedition or
something like that um which i think you
know i love don't get me wrong i love
documentaries about other people doing
stuff they light me up but this is a
direct you know me speaking to the
reader essentially um throughout the
entirety of this book and the call to
action around taking your own 12-hour
walk
but the really the origin story for me
was during covid so
um
i think the last literally i was looking
the last time i was on the pod um i have
a picture of you and i on march 8 2020
and i'm at your house and we've done
kind of a two-part follow-up to after
the drake passage and all that we did
you know did two-part episode and
march 8th 2020. it's crazy right like
i'm at you're so the lockdown date was
like when did the nba called off 11 11
11. so three days later i have this
vivid memory of standing with you the
you know the the microphones are off
we're saying goodbye and giving you a
hug and you said to me you said
you know calling up julie and i got this
trip planned to italy in may like
because italy was you know first hit
right do you think that's gonna like
what's your take on like if you think
that's gonna happen
and i was like i literally i remember i
remember giving you a hug and being like
bro
may it's march 8th man like right by
maybe
yeah it was such an interesting like
three days later it was so weird how it
went from like well there's this thing
kind of going around but i just remember
when it was two things that happened
the nba uh called off their
games and i was like holy [ __ ] and then
tom hanks yesterday in australia and i
was like everybody come home yes i'm
gonna go to the market and stock up on
canned goods and you know that was the
start totally so i and the reason you
know of course it's funny though those
headlines that you just say actually in
the chapter 12 the last chapter this
book um i open with those say news flash
those march 11 with those headlines tom
hanks
nba canceled the season because also
jenna and i had planned to climb mount
everest together that spring
um and we talked about that that was
like exactly it was coming up yeah right
around the corner and did uh those of
course derailed that entire thing but
also
you know context for us in our life we
had i had just completed the drake
passage row a couple months before that
and then my first book the impossible
first came out on january 14th
and i had been in the kind of beginnings
of post you know book tour books out um
you know super humbled and honored to
you know hit the new york times
bestsellers list boom kovid everything's
cancelled speeches the rest of the book
tour just
like you know that's the least of the
world's problems but that was just on
our personal life what was going on like
we had this kind of whole thing mapped
out jen and i were going to everest and
it was just like just like everyone else
just life instantly you know derailed
right and it's funny to think back you
and i'm like remember thinking hugging
you and like maybe even touching your
face as we're saying goodbye and then
was like in rich's house like huh that's
not like a thing that happened to you
for a long time
um but uh so then we end up going
um
i was pretty i was pretty afraid in
those first few weeks of code but not
afraid for my own safety
necessarily but like just the societal
breakdown of like that moment of like
are they going to close this and they're
going to close the borders and are they
closing state borders and like all this
kind of stuff and jen and i live in in
jackson hole my whole family basically
is in oregon you know five sisters
parents etc jenna's parents are back
east but we have a big concentration of
family in oregon where we where i grew
up we lived a long time and so it was
kind of like i would feel more
comfortable if we were like within the
state border of oregon we didn't feel
like we could go be with my parents you
know based on their age and all that
sort of stuff of like still keeping
their distance um but my family has a
cabin on the oregon coast on a really
small little coastal town 300 people
population manzanita oregon um and so
generally a way to ride out the
apartment yeah exactly
we were like in the middle of nowhere
the rules there were which town
manzanita it's like a small beach town
on the oregon coast like south of cannon
beach north of newport i don't know the
oregon coast at all but beautiful i do
that's where i did like my
fifth step when i was in treatment at
cannon beach yeah yeah it's like 20 10
miles south of there it's close like
really close to there um anyways and the
rule in oregon was they're closing all
the beaches all the state parks but you
could be in a beach town if you
were a homeowner of that be a resident
or whatever like so you can you know
drive out from portland and walk around
the beach but if you were there you
could be there that's what like the
lockdown rules were in those first
couple months so me jenna and our dog
jack
went out
loaded up our car in wyoming drove out i
went to costco and bought like 10 100
pounds of rice
like
literally i've never i still have cans
of chili
that i bought like on march 12th or
whatever exactly yeah colin like really
i i really haven't seen you that scared
i scared in different ways but in that
like kind of materialistic gathering
hoarding yeah
even jenna was like it's a little more
low-key about it but anyways we end up
in oregon coast and
we kind of had had this whole plan i
mean jenna had trained
jenna said i want to climb everest which
was really cool we can talk about that
it's incredible but
she without you know she just said not a
big background that a year before that i
want to climb everest so we've been
training for that we do the drake
passage row book tour all these kind of
things we kind of had mapped out like a
pretty 2020 year of doing this big
documentary with discovery and this all
of a sudden just cancel cancel cancel
cancelled so we find ourselves sitting
in the oregon coast
just kind of staring at each other a
little bit i mean i think a lot of
people have that moment of just kind of
like what are we doing what are we doing
now and i'm like in my house
you know like this and so in that moment
i'll i'll be honest you know my my
mental health definitely suffered um was
not was not feeling good you know days
would go by where i'd be like get up in
my pajamas and it'd be like 8pm i'd be
like still in my pajamas and be like i
guess we're just going back to sleep and
i love the oregon coast it's just a
special place but it's you know it's
rainy and dreary and it's pacific
northwest in the spring you know kill me
now and
yeah it's not this la 73 and sony every
day um
and i'm sitting there and i think to
myself when was the last time that i
felt like really deeply at peace like
when was the last time just in my body
and soul where i felt just calm and like
comfortable um and
it hadn't even been in the previous year
before covet you know it was great to
write that first book and get all the
attention off the antarctic crossing was
was really you know humbling but it also
came with a lot of feel like elevated
pressure and intensity and different
stresses and all of that and then boom
we did this rowing project which was
successful was awesome which is
exciting but stressful and so there was
a last time that i really thought of
myself feeling comfortable and calm in
that moment was
during my antarctica crossing like by
myself alone walking around out there
and
as you know because you lived at rich
you were in new york city right after my
antarctica crossing and it was the first
time i was really asked any questions by
you know
hotel lobby we ran into each other yeah
so serendipitous it was so special yeah
for those listening rich and i have come
i come in new york city after the
anarcho crossing running toward each
other hotel lobby and basically midtown
right you're on your well what i
remember about that is it was winter and
it was like kind of sleeting out a
little bit and you just finished
antarctica and you were headed over to
cnn yep and and we were like really
close to columbus circle and we were
laughing because
they they said do you want us to send a
car like you couldn't walk from it was
like four blocks
so we had to brave we thankfully had a
car we'd have to brave the main streets
of manhattan but in that moment and you
you came to my friend's house a couple
days later i think after that where
friends gathered and just said you know
asking me questions about antarctica and
what was the resonant from that moment
that ends up being the last chapter of
that book um and still is to this day is
one of the most beautiful moments of my
life just this resonance of infinite
love this sort of beauty and creativity
of that moment and sitting there in
covid i was kind of brought back to that
moment of going like wow when i had
nothing when i was alone in antarctica
walking for days
starving hungry under this like
incredible stress externally i actually
found this deep place of like peace and
contentment and so i say to jenna i kind
of i'm like i'm like i'm going out
tomorrow and she's like okay and i was
like i'm going on a walk she's like yeah
we walk every day and i was like no no
no all day 12 hours like i used to do in
antarctica by myself like i'm headed out
you know onto the oregon coast and the
one one of my favorite things about the
oregon coast is that the beaches are
these just long you know basically
desolate flat beaches that are great for
walking
and so i walk out i go walk out my door
don't have like a specific planner than
to basically stay out all day um and
remember my phone buzzed in the first
you know 30 minutes like it does you
know someone texting me or some
notification or something like that and
i like do my the knee-jerk thing pick it
up and look at it and i'm like what am i
like what am i doing like and so i throw
the phone into airplane mode um and walk
for the rest of the day you know i walk
for you know
basically 12 hours um you know conjuring
what i had done in antarctica
and tapped back into very quickly just
the the flow the the meditative bliss
the silence the stillness of my own
brain my own psyche without sort of the
external inputs of noise or sound or
even you know music or podcasts or
anything of just like the silence like
of my own brain and i came back and i
don't know what your memory of this
jenna but just i i remember just feeling
more calm and at ease than i had felt in
a really long time yeah he just had this
like kind of the spark was back in his
eye
um
which it had completely gone away you
know and in him setting out that day i
had heard it in his voice you know when
you know your partner really well and
i'm like oh he's on to something like
something is about to
have a change and him coming back in and
walking back through the door that what
day he i mean he was changed he was just
different he was
more calm more fulfilled you just felt
like happy again yeah and i think you
know in that moment when in that covered
moment couple months in the pandemic
when everyone's you know just me me and
billions of other people on the planet
trying to figure out what the heck's
going on you know the isolation
something i always thought i was really
familiar with but it was weird to be
isolated in the context of modern
society i guess yeah is that weird thing
of like i got this like i know how to be
alone yeah like i'm the guy who watches
an article alone like what do i have to
worry about and then four months later
you're like yeah this isn't so good no
and so
what came from that i mean that was the
initial spark but ultimately it was kind
of like wow
you know i've
you know i've done several 10 day of
apos silent vipasta meditations i've
walked across antarctica by myself
completely alone like you know i've done
these things are pretty intense out
there solo adventures but all of a
sudden i walk out my front door and i
basically get the same sort of
experience in terms of just in the
internal experience of just a reset a
quieting of the mind a calmness an inner
strength etc
and so
it just kind of the spark of this thesis
was
is this me being able to tap into my
experiences that i've gone to the
extreme ends of the earth to kind of
conjure within my own psyche or is this
something that's likely a could be a
prescription for
any person at any moment of time and
i've been thinking about writing another
book but i thought to myself as as proud
as i am of the impossible first
you know that's a memoir about my life
that's me just like the finding ultra is
about your life it's an incredible i
mean finding ultra love the book
incredible story it's you talking about
your life it's me talking about my life
and there's implicit things that are
guiding principles of sharing sort of
other things people can take from that
but i became more interested in the idea
of is there a book that i can write that
takes my experiences but they can
actually give somebody something
actionable and something tangible to
take home themselves not just like well
unless i go to the summit of everest
with my wife or i go to cross antarctica
solar if i wrote a boat or this i'm not
going to be able to have this feeling so
like that's just not me
and so when i did this 12 hour walk
thing i was like wow like this was
amazing
it conjured all the things that i'm
trying to like conjure my own self to
like knock me out of this kind of low
moment
and could this apply to other people so
i very quickly kind of drafted some test
subject jenna included um and said jenna
i'm gonna need you to go out and walk
for 12 hours
um and you know from that the the
12-hour walk which yes it's a book um
now but is also what i'm really thinking
about more than anything is this global
movement you know my goal is to inspire
10 million people to take a 12 hour walk
and
the book breaks breaks it down and goes
through all these limiting beliefs and
it'll entertain you from all these
stories from our life etc but at its
core i mean to you know rick corgan
probably happened to be saying this but
like it is simple like walk out your
front door put your phone on airplane
mode take a day by yourself and look
12 hours might sound far and long but
this is not an endurance challenge this
is meant to meet you exactly where
you're at like if you if you walk one
mile or if you walk 50 miles like it
doesn't matter take as many breaks as
you want like this is not like something
you're building up to this is something
for you to take a day because although
of course there's a physical element to
it ultimately this is you training your
mind
and taking that day on plug i mean i'd
love to ask you rich what for you you're
you know somebody who's endurance sport
athlete who have done some incredible
things meditation practice all as soon
as you've done but once like in the last
five years say what's the longest that
you have spent by yourself with no
external inputs and what i'll define
that which is sleeping doesn't count of
course um the second someone's in a room
with you talking to you that clock
resets every time you look at your phone
the clock resets every time you've got
music on or podcast on or whatever the
clock resets like i'm curious like
what's the longest period of time you've
spent i mean i'll tell you it ain't 12
hours you know the only thing that comes
to mind was a portion of like 29029 you
know when we were there together and i
woke up really early one morning and
kind of went up and did a couple spins
by myself yeah maybe that was a couple
hours yeah and that's probably where our
i've maxed out and i were in the tent
adjacent to you and i think we kept you
up
jenna came back late and we were being
loud or something like that i couldn't
sleep and then you guys got home yeah
you guys came back really late we're in
the tent next to me and woke me up and i
was like [ __ ] it i'm awake i'm just
gonna go back up on the mountain in the
dark you know which was fine
before us but then we're like rich you
got to do a victory lap with us yeah and
then i got [ __ ] for like like i snuck
out and like you know sandbagged
everybody like that was not the
intention trust me i wish i could have
slept in yeah um but yeah the point
being that you know i haven't you know
even as somebody who loves all of these
things and appreciates the
the value that they bring like my life's
busy and i got you know lots of moving
pieces around me and you know i haven't
carved out the time to do something like
that but i think that the beauty in all
of it is
the simplicity of it and how easy it is
to understand and the fact that it's
taking
the core of the aspirational and making
it entirely accessible you know even if
you walk a mile and sit on a rock for
you know most the day or whatever you're
still engaging in this process it's a
no-cost affair
and it's not
demanding physically or it's not
necessarily demanding physically it's
really a walkabout it's a compressed
silent meditative practice in which
you're compelled to confront yourself
without devices to distract you or
entertain you totally yeah exactly and i
think it what's what's fun and
interesting about about that concept and
why i'm really excited about it is i'm
not here to vilify social media like
being like don't ever be on social media
don't ever check your phone in life i'm
just saying like hey like this day take
a day take one day i mean the subtitle
of the book is invest one day conk your
mind unlock your best life i think we
can have i know
if you're feeling stuck if you're
feeling depressed if you're having a
tough time if if you're not feeling even
stuck or depressed but you're just like
wanna reset or you're you're pondering a
career change or a shift or anything's
going on your mind like
it is so easy in the middle of our
day-to-day with all of our
responsibilities to not take the time to
kind of look inward um and one of the
book one of the the the chapters on this
book that i'm really passionate about is
around intuition um and that's through
the frame of my k2 expedition which we
haven't we haven't spoken about we'll
talk about some point but the
is is kind of i say when you know you
know like you know the answer like it's
amazing how we actually and a lot of the
big decisions in our life know the
answer um but we don't give ourselves
the time to reflect on the oh this this
to-do list or this pros and cons or
whatever but 12-hour walk opens the
possibility for that as well and so you
know i mean to me what's so fun about
this is i love being the athlete in the
arena again like i said proud of those
things but this is saying like you know
my my next mount everest is for everyone
listening for everyone to be a part of
this to be involved in this we uh you
can do the 12-hour walk any single day
we've actually created an app funny
enough for this sort of thing that
basically puts your phone in airplane
mode and counts down but also keeps maps
open so you don't get lost um you know
which is helpful um
but also on
september 10th we have a larger sort of
call to action right which is you're
going to let's do it you're going to
everybody's going to everyone's going to
do it on that on that on that
individually but together yeah so
goggins has the 4 by 4 by 48 you go you
got the 12x1 yeah the 1251. i like it
so rich what are you doing on september
10th
sometimes i actually already put it on
my calendar amazing um so i already have
it blocked off to do it uh there's a
possibility i might be out of town doing
something but i don't i'm not sure in
which case i'll do it you know
beforehand amazing but uh yeah i already
made a point of making sure it's it's
there i love it i think i think it's
cool one thing that i love it and i i'm
really curious to hear your feedback on
it the people that we've had you know
test doing this it's been amazing people
oh you know all different ages you know
all the way up to people in late 70s
have done this to friends of ours
contemporary friends of ours younger you
know people who have never done anything
you know never done a 5k never a 10k no
not like non-athletes like really a wide
cross-section of people
and the
just the original initial feedback's
been amazing you know people crying
people having these breakthroughs but
one things i found the most interesting
about
committing to do it like if you're
listening to this and you're thinking
like am i going to do that am i not
going to do that is
the limiting beliefs that pop up in your
mind when thinking about doing this like
literally like you haven't even done it
yet but like you're listening this
you're driving your car right now you're
listening to this podcast and you're
like yeah but like i'm a busy guy and
like where am i gonna find the time
right or i hate being uncomfortable you
know i just don't like being
uncomfortable if i'm on my feet that
long that's just not going to feel that
good you know your listeners i think are
more like kind of step outside their
comfort zone folks but that's a pretty
common experience people just kind of
wanting to not you know push a little
bit or i'm not strong enough right i'm
not a runner i'm not a walker i'm not a
you know those limiting beliefs are
popping up around why not to schedule
the 12-hour walk and then kind of diving
deep and writing this book what i
realized is
whatever limiting beliefs are coming up
for you myself included when i try to
put this on my own calendar because i'm
now doing this somewhat regularly
i realized those are the same limiting
beliefs that are also holding me back
from
unlocking my best life or doing the
things that i want to do so for right
now the first excuse is i don't have
enough time it's likely
that you're also saying that limiting
belief to yourself in a number of other
buckets in your own life that are
holding you back so i think it's an
interesting the 12-hour walk the
experience of the one day
is incredibly powerful to get through it
not least of which because
to get to the point of saying yep it's
on my calendar september 10th i'm doing
it you actually have to fight against
the mirror of your own limiting beliefs
to get there but on the other side of it
i mentioned it before
you unlock what i call the possible
mindset this all of a sudden you're like
whoa if i can do that if i can commit to
that if i can push through that if i can
spend that day alone with myself what
else can i do what else can i unlock
what other pieces what other limiting
beliefs can i shed and get past and so
for that reason i think it's really
valuable as well not just even the 12
hours but the experience of getting to
the start line so to speak as you well
know the difference being
between something like this and a
marathon like if you if you are going to
do a marathon you got to register you
pay the fee
maybe you got to fly to the city you got
to book the hotels and so there's that
um external kind of pressure like well i
spent all this money like i have to see
this through but with this it's like
yeah i didn't like i can just back out
like no one's gonna give a [ __ ]
until we get that fomo going on you know
until we get but yeah no 100 and that's
where it's intentionally it's
intentionally clean in terms of like
it's simple it's like yo this costs no
money
people immediately go to well when i'm
on vacation and i'm in this beautiful
place and i this whatever and like if
you want to wait to that fine but don't
like a mood follows action thing so
you're waiting for the world to you know
create the perfect circumstance as
opposed to just saying well tomorrow's
as good as any other day because i don't
have to go to work so i'm just gonna do
it and i actually have found with the
people that we've tested doing it um
people walking out their front door
actually have in a lot of ways an even
more profound experience um
allie rogers who i know you you and i
have both done a lot of a lot of work
with over the years so she'd create a
bunch of amazing video edits so inside
of this book there's a bunch of qr codes
that you can scan and kind of brings you
into these videos right each chapter is
is sort of a prescriptive
uh it kind of ends with some
prescriptive stuff based on stories that
you tell about your experiences uh and
then the qr code leads you to like these
videos that are like
there's some pretty intense videos there
like you know footage from you you know
at your lower moments on you know on the
you know like base camp and all that
kind of crazy [ __ ] but the so ali was
was also one of the original test
subjects of this
and
she walked out her front door in
minneapolis in december middle of winter
in december you know um and does a
12-hour walk and it was awesome to hear
her reflections um i don't think she
would mind me sharing this here but of
her being like oh i walked past the
house of my old friend from when i was
10 and realized you know oh this memory
came up or this memory from childhood or
kind of an old grievance with a certain
thing like the echoes that you have in
and around your hometown or your front
door your local community it's
interesting both on a positive and
negative but it's a very grounding
part of your life particularly when you
have the stillness of your own mind when
i was walking across antarctica memories
would come back to me and they'd replay
in these visceral details and so again
you can do the 12-hour walk anywhere but
i really do encourage people to do it
right out their front door not like i'm
saving it up to be on the vacation to be
here to be there it's like yo like no
more excuses like saturday you're gonna
be home you don't have to work that day
figure out child care and you walk out
your front door because it also then as
you go about your day-to-day life the
following day the following week the
following month you have this imprint
from the walk where you're like oh i
remember on hour seven when i was on the
corner of you know fifth and main or you
know wherever that is in your hometown
going like huh and it can bring you back
to that place of feeling empowered and
strong um which i think is is a really
cool byproduct um of doing it out your
front door as well yeah so jenna what
was your experience of doing the walk
yeah so colin comes up with this idea
and i'm test subject number one
um we were spending time in moab at the
time so
um after the oregon coast yeah after the
wrinkles so november 2020 is when i took
my first 12 hour walk and
just like colin said i
it took me weeks to come up with the
right the right day to schedule it
because i was like i don't have time on
this day and this is too distracting oh
but my ankle kind of hurts like should i
let that heal a little bit
and
finally you were just like jenna that's
not the point the point is put the day
on the calendar commit to it and walk
out the front door and i was like okay i
can't remember the exact date but it was
november something 2020. 2020
and i had been staring at this ridgeline
that was kind of outside of the house
and i was like you know what i'm just
going to like wander up that road and
see where see where i go and
i spent literally six hours walking up
this meandering ridgeline and just so in
awe of the beauty
um that was surrounding me i don't know
if you've been to moab before but it's a
pretty stunning place with the red rocks
and
um i mean for me it was
a complete sense of clarity um actually
around family that's just kind of what
kept coming up and resonating for me
and
you know we're looking forward to
becoming parents at some point soon and
and taking on that next big adventure
which i know you're very
familiar with um but even more so you
know my parents um they're aging my dad
turned 85 this year and my mom will be
78 in a few a few months she probably
wouldn't want me to say that but um
and i'm sure she's listening
oh yeah she listens to everything we do
so she will be rich
um
and i just really had this kind of clear
centered understanding of i don't have
that much more time left with them
and i think as a result of that you know
i came home with just this deep
resonance of i need to spend more time
with my family um you know we've chosen
to live in jackson hole and like colin
mentioned his family lives in oregon and
my family is on the east coast and so
the christmas after that we gathered 15
family members for christmas in jackson
hole and it was so special and just a
really beautiful
reminder both to not only gather for big
holiday events but small ones and i just
think
you know i had come up with all the
excuses of why i couldn't make the trip
out of easter why you know it was just
harder to fit in um but knowing like
that deep knowing after taking the walk
and on the walk being like oh this is
what's really important right so the
walk catalyzed that awareness that
allowed you to kind of create that
reality yeah that's really cool
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but i want
to snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition the thing is
most people i know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables seeds beans and
legumes into their daily routine sadly
however without the kitchen tools and
support very few end up sticking with it
so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle and solve this very
common problem the solution we've
devised i'm proud to say is the plant
power meal planner our affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for nutrition excellence by
providing access to thousands of highly
customizable super delicious and easy to
prepare plant-based recipes everything
integrates with automatic grocery
delivery and you get access to our
amazing
team of nutrition coaches seven days a
week and many other features to learn
more and to sign up visit
meals.richrol.com
and right now for a limited time we're
offering ten dollars off an annual
membership when you use the promo code
rr health at checkout this is
life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee again that's
meals.richrol.com promo code rrhealth
for ten dollars off an annual membership
all right
let's get back to the show i also like
that
um it's
this whole thing is
in contrast to the impulse of somebody
like you who's always thinking what's
the crazier thing and the bigger thing
that i can do and it's like you've done
all this stuff
how long can you chase that
you know notion of like the next thing i
have that i'm gonna do has to be bigger
and more impressive and just to bring it
back to
something relatable and very doable
in a in a kind of sharing way totally
and i think i think as i've you know
gone around and done a lot of public
speeches and met all sorts of people in
different contexts and things like that
and you know
certainly people love to ask me
questions about my you know world
records and different feats and things
like that and don't get me wrong i'm
happy to tell those stories and share
that i've certainly learned so much and
in the book you know tell those stories
and vivid rich detail you know edge of
the seat kind of storytelling stuff to
apply these lessons um
but
i'm fascinated by humans i'm fascinated
by stories and i think that
too often people think oh well you have
this story so i don't want to share my
story because it's not important or it's
not as big or grandiose or something
like that and that couldn't be farther
than my orientation the world like i am
fascinated by every single person i'm
sitting across every single story that's
being shared and i think we all are
walking through this life just trying to
figure it out right good days bad days
everything in between and so to me what
i'm so excited about the 12-hour walk is
of course i get off the stage i'm the
speaking engagement and i just told
somebody about how i was the first
person to cross antarctica and supported
you know no kites no dog you know
whatever you know make this crossing
that no one had done yet
and the first thing is like well this is
so unrelatable like that's cool man like
crazy inspiring but like i'm probably
never going to go down articulate and
walk across it
um other than my pal lou rudd who i do
still stay in touch with from that guy
oh that's good to hear but uh in this
context what's fun is to have
a common frame uh i'm excited for this
book to come out and for people to
participate in this and sit across from
people and ask the same question that
you just asked jenna like i'm excited
next time i see you to be like rich what
was your experience with a 12-hour walk
what was your experience with the
12-hour walk and just to hear the the
difference of all the different things
the good the bad the emotions the
processing the ripple effect of
decisions made um in those moments you
know even just in the small test group
of people we've had do it over the
course of the year or so building this
book people have been like oh my god i
thought about this and i took these
actions and now i am doing x with my
life or i'm i've made this shift or i've
made this change um and so from that
standpoint i'm super fascinated because
i love the idea of mindset i love the
idea that we all have this you know i
say i love to say the most important
muscle any of us have is the six inches
between our ears you know we all have
that we all have this mental capacity
young old you know depending on
measuring your circumstance we have this
ability to flex and develop this and to
me it's exciting to being really not
just a book but to launching an idea a
movement of sorts into the world that
people can have a shared common
experience around which is individual
which is solo but also the collective
whole which is why again september 10th
it's like hey we're doing this you're
doing this alone from your front door
i'm going to be walking you're going to
be walking we're going to be walking
together alone together but there's that
common experience that accountability to
how can we all grow from this what can
we learn what are our own unique
experiences from that so for me that
that piece of was exciting i was i was
laughing before when you were talking
about walking up and down that road um
when you did it you told me don't tell
what was like a guy drop was it like i
mean i was on the same road so i i left
the front door walked out onto you know
like a small street there's a wide
shoulder um and you know it was dawn
when i left and i'm walking up this
large hill actually and the car drives
by you know a few cars pass me on the
way and then
six hours later i'm at the top i have
some water or whatever turn around walk
back down and it's like
probably dusk like it's getting late
um the sun is definitely setting and
i've been out there obviously i'm you
know sweaty and whatever it was moab and
warm and
this car
comes down the road and is like slowing
down next to me and i'm like oh what is
this the guy rolls down his window and
he's like
hey um
i'm not trying to like distract you or
interrupt you but like
were you walking on this road this
morning
uh
do you need a ride
[Laughter]
and i was like oh my gosh thank you so
much i actually set out to walk all day
for 12 hours
and he
was a little taken aback but was like oh
my god that is so cool and then he just
kept like cheering for me like you know
for a little ways down the road but it
was a really good moab's a place where
people go to have long walks exactly
it's a good place for it
it was a great kind of like community
moment where people were clearly
noticing i mean several cars have passed
i'm sure other people noticed that i was
out there for a long time um but that
they you know stopped to take take a
minute understand what i was doing and
and just have the the graciousness to be
like are you okay do you need anything
right right yeah yeah and if something
goes terribly wrong are you allowed to
take your phone off airplane yeah so
they're having this so
to be clear this is the liability
there's a liability if the lawyer has
asked me the liability question um you
know in the back of the book um there's
a list of faqs and then that also links
off to the website which has even more
faqs um which is again it's completely
freaking the same time but i encourage
people to actually sign up so i can
share more information with you which is
emails from me you know basically being
able to have a little bit of a dialogue
um and one of them of course is around
safety it's like bring a head lamp wear
bright clothes if you're walking on a
street without sidewalks walk in the
direction of the trap so left side if
you're in the right side driving country
it's like
but in the phone hold on here's my idea
yeah
this
should build us into it
if i don't care what happens but if you
have to take your phone off airplane
mode
the clock goes back to minute one that's
right yeah i gotta read it
you heard it here first the app like i
said we built an app 12 hour walk app
that basically puts your phone on
airplane mode gives you a few prompts
and things to set some intentions as you
set off and effectively is a counter and
a google maps interface inside of the
app again so you can because i don't
want people to have to be like clicking
on their phone and turning it back on
off so the gps actually works with your
phone off so you know the blue dot will
move around you can zoom in and out of
the map um so we've solved that problem
for you guys so there's really no
excuses but i don't know i should plug
into my app and tell my the dev guy to
say if the airplane mode gets triggered
off and there's a phone call made it
usually shuts the app down it's like
yeah like the whole your whole phone is
like ready
my mom did the walk um she'd kept her
phone in airplane mode the entire time
but she did from her front door
she lives in hood river oregon um and uh
she did a point to point though so she
said i want to walk in one direction to
see just mentally it's better to do it
do it that way yeah you know you can't
turn around right i will say my turn
around i was like oh man yeah yeah
yeah and you would walk i mean i would
walk downhill downhill beats the legs up
but the uh but yeah so she had range
with my stepdad hey i'm gonna not get on
my phone on this time but i'm gonna turn
it on at this time and give you a call
and share my position with you which is
you know she ended up wherever out in
the dallas or something like that no in
that area i was like you know she walked
you know i don't know 25 30 miles or
something like that um
but uh and that's and that even that's
kind of a fun thing for her she loved
the walk in so many ways and she also
lives you know in this semi-rural part
of oregon and she's like someone she's
like like she's driving to the costco
which is the next town over in hood
river or excuse me in the dalles and
she's like
oh this is the 30 minute drive of my car
but like i walked here and beyond this
like she's like very like you know proud
of that in her early 60s just like heck
yeah you did like that's super cool so
people interpret it a lot of different
ways but the the single direction is
definitely something that i think people
will do as well and i say that in the
book i say look you have to plan your
out ahead of time just like life you
choose a destination but like put on the
walk-in shoes step out your front door
so the book opens the introduction of
the book is this story that feels like
it's right out of an episode of billions
you know and so i'm interested in maybe
you could tell that story and why you
chose that anecdote to
contextualize this narrative yeah
yeah so um
again early 2020 right before the
pandemic um
kind of in that area of the book tour of
the impossible first speaking
engagements things like that coming back
from the row um i was invited to give a
speech to a bunch of wall street bankers
and they had invited me you know to i
think the audience was 500 people or
something like that
but the night before they said hey we'd
love to have you over to this dinner
just kind of like a smaller more
intimate group to kind of meet you um in
a small context there's only going to be
you know eight people there or something
like that and i was like great
and so
um i am in manhattan new york city um
i've gotten i've gotten to know
manhattan over the years but i was you
know a public school kid from portland
oregon raised in a you know lower middle
class part of the city you know new
york's always been kind of like big
bright lights big you know big big
pumping fast city um for me
and i i've always i don't know i don't
know if you have this experience even
more of an east you grew up on the east
coast but like doorman like being like
having like a doorman is like always
like kind of like i don't know it feels
like having like a chaperone or like
somebody like an overlord or something
like that even though i know it's like a
nice fancy thing to have in new york
but um
it's actually funny enough wearing the
exact same thing that i'm wearing right
now which i very common outfit for me
black t-shirt you know low top jordans i
walk through into this you know lobby of
this very very fancy um upper east side
apartment and i get this look from the
dorm excuse me sir like where are you
going what you know why why are you
coming in here like whatever and i was
like oh like i'm invited to this thing
and the guide should never forget the
doorman like looks at me and he's like
no you're not like just like and he says
to me if you never forget he says to me
if you're with catering you need to take
the service elevator he's just like
super just like straight to the heart
like you don't belong here and i was
kind of like oh i think i'm in the right
place it's this apartment the name
whatever realize i'm in the right place
and he sends me up and i'm in this you
know fancy elevator um and i've only
seen this a handful of times but it's
some of those fancy elevators that like
actually goes directly into the
penthouse and then you open into yeah
it's not like a lobby or like a floor
it's like the elevator goes like into
the foyer of this person's like insane
new york city apartment and that was the
case so doors open boom i'm in this
penthouse apartment
and there's you know a group of guys and
they're all you know
65 i just guess you know mid 60s to
later in life um and you know we sit sit
down for dinner and you know these guys
are suited and booted you know custom
tailored suits the patek philippe rolex
watching you know the lots of big water
yeah big watches and the whole deal and
i'm sitting here t-shirting jeans and
you know little top jordans um you know
just being myself really and we have at
dinner um you know the host was super
generous introduces me everyone kind of
introduces themselves and you know these
guys are all you know you know i'm
speaking of 500 wall street guys who are
all you know doing great i guess in the
wall street scene but these are the you
know the the fund managers or the ceo of
this or that the other thing um
and
you know we have a conversation um the
start talking about different
expeditions i share with them you know
certain you know stories of antarctica
and you know they're curious about
everest and have you seen dead bodies on
everest this kind of stuff and you know
something i've been asking people for
years now starting with school kids and
i've asked it to thousands and thousands
of people now as i stop the room at one
point and i say you guys been asking me
all these questions it's great
conversation but like i want to know
more about you guys like what's your
what's your everest like what did you
dream about when you were a kid is was
it this like was it being right where
you are you guys have obviously been
wildly successful like what is your
everest
um and
i expected there to be sort of this like
raucous response of like oh yeah like i
set out to buy this or you know own this
or do this and all these things you guys
were clearly like the quote unquote
american dream of the pinnacle of
success
and there was sort of just this awkward
like kind of like they're all kind of
looking at each other and like no one
says anything and it was just like a
it was a noticeable moment of just kind
of like huh like
i get it like i ask little kids this
question and i get kids raising their
hands you know i want to be the first
person my everest to be the first person
in my family to graduate from college or
my mount everest is making sure the snow
leopards are off the endangered species
list of course i don't you know expect
that from a group of 65 70 year old you
know really successful bankers but i did
expect sort of some passion around
you know what their everest was in their
lives
anyway so after this sort of awkward
moment the conversation kind of
continues on and we finish up the dinner
and i'm getting ready to go and getting
ready to get back in this uh this this
elevator and go home for the night and
go to give the speech um the next day
and this guy
was the oldest gentleman at the table um
like if i had a guest maybe 75 something
like that walks over to me and i'm about
to get in the elevator and he kind of
grabs me by the shoulder and he says hey
hey yeah colin can i can i speak to you
privately for a second it kind of pulls
me away from the rest of the group
super sincere um soft-spoken guy
um you know just like the rest of them
obviously very successful
in his career and he kind of pulls me
aside and he says like you know you
asked us an important question there and
i'm embarrassed to say that like none of
us really gave you an answer myself
included
and he's like ever since you asked that
i had asked it maybe you know an hour
before that you know before dessert or
whatever in this conversation
like he's like i just been sitting here
thinking about this
and like
i don't know if i have an answer
and he was kind of stumbling over his
words but in essence um he says to me
like
i've made more money than you could
possibly imagine in my life
but he paints this picture me goes but i
used to go to the summer camp and i
think it was the catskills and i used to
sit on this row boat summer camp when i
was a you know in my early adolescence
and he goes there's not a day that goes
by where my mind doesn't drift back to
this moment on this boat at summer camp
the simplicity of these days
and it kind of leaves it hanging there
um and we have a little bit more of a
dialogue and i write it write it more
succinctly in in the book um
but in essence he's saying to me
without saying it like kind of like
i don't know i've i've had all this
quote-unquote external success made all
this money
but i'm not that fulfilled
is essentially what he was saying to me
um it's like he never took the time to
actually ask himself the question what
his everest was he started off on a path
and just kind of let the river right
take it or the everest was the you know
financial success and the power that
comes with that
only to discover that it didn't provide
the fulfillment that those simple uh you
know memories seem to serve for him yeah
and so it was it it certainly that
moment has stood out for me so
significantly in my life you know over
the years a couple years since then um
and certainly in the the essence of this
12-hour walk you know i asked the reader
directly to answer that question for
themselves after sharing this story
which is what is your everest you're
taking this walk like what's your
everest frame it like think about like
what is something you're trying to this
isn't necessarily about achievement it's
not like oh i want x amount of dollars
it's like you know
family friends relationships career
health i mean it can be anything but
kind of having that that moment right
you know conjuring that possible mindset
like jen and i did on that mountaintop
what do we want the remainder of our
days to be like whether you're 80 years
old and you're you know have most of
your life in the rearview mirror most
likely or you're you know 20 years old
like but just having a moment to ask
that question
and i think what really stuck out to me
and particularly
you know where i where i come from my
background etc is it's very easy to you
know you said it's like an episode out
of billions like to imagine the the room
with the 100 millionaire billionaire
guys and be like well they did it like
they're this is like success and
happiness or whatever i don't know what
happens the right word but just like
they did it like they crushed life they
they won the game you know essentially
um
and to have this insincerity of this guy
just basically be like kind of really
vulnerable with me in a quiet moment of
being like man like i have all this but
there's something more um
and so it framed to me for me this idea
which is
whether you're
that guy
or you're any number of other archetypes
or people living this life this thing we
call life which is meaning
you can be stuck challenged depressed
having a hard moment fulfilled
unfulfilled hoping to have more hoping
to have less whatever
but if you don't take that moment to
check in with yourself if you don't ask
there's no right answer to the question
what's my everest there's literally no
right answer the only wrong answer is
not asking the question not taking the
time to actually answer the question but
more importantly take action towards
that and it's not a
the book the 12-hour walk itself isn't a
manifesto of blow up everything in your
life and make every change tomorrow if
that's the significant sweeping change
that you need to make in this moment
great like that's your path
but it's also just a check-in of just
saying like hey like
man like i mean it reminds me a little
bit of i'm not going to try to project
too much on you but you in your late 30s
early 40s with your law career and not
being as fit as you were as a swimmer
and this just going like wait like what
like is this my life like
and and you obviously found this whole
other vocation calling beautiful path
since then but not without actually
having the guts the gall to say wait a
second
well there was there was an inflection
point for that
but
the endurance piece was really a version
of the 12-hour walk it's all that time
spent alone
where you're wrestling with those
questions and you're just you're living
in the experience of trying to figure it
out and it's not about the answer as
much as it is about like
the willingness to like grapple with it
you know like what could it be what
would be good
i don't know like being honest with
yourself and trying to figure out like
what a better path would you know could
look like a hundred percent and that's
that's where i think the the power
what's so interesting and what i think
is powerful about um
the prescription of the 12-hour walk for
lack of a better word is
we're all different we're all thinking
about different things this this idea of
this 12-hour walk is meeting you at a
specific moment in time in your life
like i don't have the answer this book
is chocked full of prescriptive advice
saying hey this is how i overcame you
know i have myself colin and brady have
dealt with all of these limiting beliefs
and let me tell you i mean i throw you
into all these stories where i am deeply
fearing failure i'm deeply fearing
criticism i'm deeply you know actually
failing you know or feeling like money's
not abundant like i i am experiencing
all these limiting beliefs and i share
stories in a rich way
that to get you know gets you kind of
interested in the storytelling of that
but i zoom out from it and go and my
advice on getting through that is x y
and z i think it's powerful i think it's
it's strong advice but at its core i'm
actually saying but you actually have
the answer for yourself i'm not gonna
try to pretend like i understand or i am
you know some omniscient god-like
presence that understands every single
person's circumstance or point of view
i'm just saying
you can definitely gain something in
your circumstance by taking this day
alone in your thoughts walking and being
in your body and mind the same way that
you were as an endurance athlete you
know in this inflection point in your
life the same way i was walking across
antarctica but realizing any person
listening to this is like yo i can walk
out my front door and tap into this sort
of inner knowing about this and actually
overcome these limiting beliefs and make
make even if it's a you know to summon
james clear a one percent difference
every single day is is all that you know
it's it's multiplied over time is
compound interest in in your life of
shifting making those changes towards
your best life and so i think the
12-hour walk i know the 12-hour walk can
be a huge catalyst for positive change
and i'm just excited to share it with so
many people yeah nice man well i want to
change gears here let's talk about k2 i
mean it's been you know an interesting
year and a half uh for you guys in terms
of expeditions and challenges and loss
yeah yeah
um
yeah k2 i mean it's ultimately
a sad story um but came from also a
really beautiful place
and something that you know jen and i
were able to share part of that journey
in the physical space together which was
really beautiful
um we
you know coming out of covid thinking
about expeditions etc
mountain you know jenna had jenna had
trained for a year to climb everest in
the fall of 20 excuse me in the spring
of 2020 from the chinese side we had
flights to china on april 4th 2020.
i want to hear from jennifer that's not
a great has been quiet over there
talk about yeah like you're getting your
head around that
yeah i mean obviously we'll dovetail
back into k2 but um
yeah i mean i had i really had raised my
hand and said like can i climb everest
do you think we can do this um do you
think i can do this and and colin was
like i think if you trained for it sure
i totally think you can do it and so um
we were living in jackson hole and i i
really did put my head down and i i
trained i mean i climbed up snow king
every day i did hit workouts which is
you know i'm not like the most like
go to the gym kind of person
but i did like i did it and obviously
column was very much so overseeing that
um and
sure enough you know the time was
passing and it had been a year and it
was march of 2020 and we were meant to
fly to china to climb everest together
from the north side and obviously that
got shut down very quickly um
and and in the aftermath of that of
course i was really upset at the time i
was like oh man like i i finally set my
own personal goal right not not a
call-in goal i set my own goal and it
just it didn't work out it didn't pan
out and so i think just the the defeat
of that was i mean it was it shook me
enough to say like i'm not gonna that
goal i'm just gonna let it go like it
wasn't meant to be i guess and then kind
of in that same moment where we're
describing the oregon coast where i'm
kind of struggling with my own you know
desire passion the 12-hour walk is born
the same thing for you you just were
like i'm done like i'm like i was like
we could push the training another year
whatever and jenna was just like like no
i'm all like this like there's way
bigger problems in the world there's way
too much going on like i don't need to
hold on to that
um it wasn't a childhood dream of mine
it really was you know kind of watching
colin in the mountains and experiencing
that firsthand and knowing friends and i
was like it's just kind of like question
mark like well maybe i could do it too
um
and then after kind of that year i was
just like
i'm gonna take my name out of the hat on
that one and then
so then later in that year
you know the himalayas both the chinese
and the nepalese side were completely
closed the other part of the world where
between china and nepal you know the 14
8 000 meter peaks are the 14 tallest
mountains you know in the world the
other region of the world is the
karakoram in pakistan so there's five of
the 14 tallest mountains in the world
are in pakistan including k2 which is
the second tallest mountain in the world
a little bit
shorter than everest not a lot
but significantly more dangerous um
significantly more challenging
technically um and
the um
the 14 8 000 meter peaks have you seen
14 p the nims movie or i haven't watched
it yet yeah i can't believe i still
haven't gotten around yet because
everyone says it's unbelievable yeah
it's great you know and you know we've
we nems is a part of this this story as
well on k2 but um basically
the um
the 14 8 000 meter peaks for you know
catching people who haven't seen that
movie or don't know the context of that
those are the 14 tallest mountains in
the world um and 8 000 meters is roughly
26 000 feet and that is sort of what's
known as the death zone the altitude
above where the human body is slowly
dying um even with supplemental oxygen
you really can't survive up there for
very long
and the mountains have all been climbed
in summer they've all been climbed solo
they've all been climbed you know kind
of lots of different ways
but only 13 out of the 14 of them have
been climbed in winter so winter of
course being much more challenging than
summer the days are shorter the
temperatures are ridiculously cold
instead of minus 30 or minus 40 you're
looking at minus 70 minus 80 you're
looking at ridiculous winds
short days so maybe only you know seven
eight hours of daylight with 16 hours of
dark dark cold night um and k2 although
had been attempted going back to the 80s
of some of the best climbers in the
world have attempted it over time had
still never been climbed in winter
and so um you know several public you
know big publications had written about
this winter k2 climb as sort of the last
great prize and high altitude
mountaineering um and again people have
tried this even recently people have
tried this and really not come close
it's not like people have been just
below the summit but it's like really
been this sort of very out of reach kind
of project
and um i guess dovetailing off my
personality or other things i've
attempted you know people having that
out there that carried out there was was
definitely interesting to me um and it
was also interesting timing which ends
up playing significantly into this
entire story of k2 which is
that people
um
since all these mountains have been
closed for the you know better part of
2020 all these professional mountaineers
around the world had been kind of stuck
at home on the bench right and all of a
sudden pakistan announces
pakistan will be open to international
climbing tourism um you know this winter
right everybody rushes in and all of a
sudden like you know k2 and winner tons
of winners no one would be attempting it
and when someone did attempt there might
be like three guys over there or like
the a group of polish national team you
know ten guys went over there and twenty
seven every
date wrong by a little bit it's not like
there was like lots of teams attempting
this like if there ever was a team it's
like a small team or one person like
whatever and all of a sudden
there were
um god what you know how many like i
mean not crazy number but like
15
plus the plus
like somewhere between like maybe 15 or
20 um of the top you know climbers from
around the world from all around the
world and a strong nepalese contingent
um but like guys from all over the world
from from south america from europe from
all these different places um and what
ended up ultimately happening for large
and large part was um this guy named
dawa who's
a sherpa really renowned climber uh had
the world record for the fort the
youngest person to climb the fourteen
eight thousand meter peaks and he's like
a um businessman now runs runs uh like a
logistics company he basically realized
all these people were kind of chomping
at the bit to do this and he was like
well how about i set up the logistics to
do this and everyone kind of comes under
the same permit meaning you're going to
climb independently from one another
once you're on the mountain but like
it's hard to get to k2 in general let
alone in the middle of winter you're
talking about you know 200 balti porters
carrying for you know 100 miles on the
longest glacier in the world the
balteral glacier um and
really insane track to get in there lots
of logistics and complicated so long
story short
most of us colluded and basically went
under this one singular permit
logistically but still with the idea of
climbing independently so i went over
there with my climbing partner dear
friend long time friend and climate
partner a guy by the name of dr john
who i've known for years who if you
follow mike posner on instagram he was
posner's guy yeah so we i was friends
with posner i introduced posner to dr
john
um they became you know dear friends and
practically brothers at this point and
dr john helped train postner for everest
um which was super cool and then
in that vein i really wanted and jenna
wanted to come to k2 and come to k2 base
camp i was not climb the mountain but
like come to the base camp the the track
in the k2 i'd never been to karakoram
but it's one of those places at least
for me that for forever right like oh
you think the himalayas are amazing you
think the alps are amazing like wait til
you see the karakoram like it's just on
another level um
and so
we we realized that we could trek in
together particularly if posner came as
well
because then posner and jenna could exit
together could exit together in the
middle of winter so anyways get on a
tangent there but basically we all check
in the four of us me dr john
posner and jenna all trek into k2
baseball this is christmas new year's
eve 2020 going into 2021 yeah and this
was part of posner's training for
everest yeah yeah yeah exactly so john
said hey this is a great training if you
have high altitude you've never been in
the expedition environment you'll meet
some of like the best climbers in the
world and just be able to kind of riff
with them and you know posers got
infectious personality you know been on
the pod a couple times and dear friend
of ours and just amazing human so uh you
know he's singing songs and you know
hanging out those videos of him
entertaining the sherpa yes you know
it's unbelievable well
as a quick aside so we go and climb we
get to to base camp only spend a couple
days there and then john might go up the
mountain we'll get into the climb itself
but it's the funniest side which is then
jenna and posner yeah leave pose and i
and one other guy leave with a bunch of
baltiporters who were bringing stuff out
and i mean it's winter this is the
coldest environment i have ever been in
this was not like chicago cold in the
middle of winter like frigid
i mean i have not been minus 30-40
yeah i mean just
really like bone chilling cold i'll
never forget it base camp's at 16 000
feet
yeah
and it's a week it's a week each way
it's a weekend it's a long trek yeah and
so pose and i and another guy named
jerry are tracking out and again there's
it's not like it's set up like oh
there's huts along the way or anything
there's like makeshift little tents and
there's maybe six balti porters with us
as well who are like cooking up over you
know a little kerosene we called it fire
in a can like it was
really primitive on the way out and
you know it's high altitude people are
coughing a little bit and
we're not really thinking so much of it
because it's so cold we're just trying
to stay warm and keep moving and
pose and i got so sick
and as you can imagine what time of year
this is winter but also like in the
middle of copen before vaccines before
vaccines and
technically we didn't test positive for
covid but we i mean
again who knows what pakistan testing
was like at that time
but we definitely got copied i mean we
were so sick like ended up in this tiny
little town of skardu the planes weren't
flying we couldn't go anywhere no
electricity cinder block out jenna gets
stuck basically in the middle of winter
in pakistan with posner in a tent first
of all for a week and then in a
cinderblock sort of hotel but with no
like they're in their sleeping bags and
down coats inside of a building like
with seeing their breath for another
what seven to ten days in skardu bag
so anyways
jenna and posner leave i think they're
making a quick exit clearly it takes
them a couple weeks and jenna you know
we've had some amazing experience with
poser over the years but i think jenna
you know in a tent with poser in the
snowstorm in pakistan these two like
know each other like they live side by
side in it together uh with covet um but
uh we end up
so basically the way high altitude
mountaineering works in short is you
climb up and down the route several
times you get acclimatized at higher
camps and you come back down the
mountain um to rest but because it's
pakistan in the middle of winter we're
coming k2 in winter like the the moments
to climb are few and far between like
we're just getting hammered in base camp
by this ridiculously cold weather and
there might be like a day or a day and a
half on the horizon where you're like
okay we're gonna go stock camp one or
stock camp two like this is our moment
there's not like lots of days where you
can move so there's a lot of being
hunkered down these tents
um
so
again we kind of collectively
logistically everyone sort of decides to
collude in the sense that like instead
of like every person putting their own
section of rope or own this or that like
it's like each part of the route that's
going to be open we know we're going to
collectively use the same fixed ropes
over rope gets put there people are
going to use it etc which makes a lot
more sense than basically a dozen
separate parties on the exact same
ridiculous how does that mesh with like
the etiquette and unspoken rules around
like what it means to summit yeah so
that i mean at this point like that's
pretty standard particularly i'm like
i'm on certainly on you know an everest
expedition now there's you know people
so many people over there at this point
where it's like there's it's pretty hard
at least in the standard route to not do
it that way it'd be really complex
otherwise people kind of do it slightly
differently a little bit of more
independence or whatever but it's hard
there's people paying into the same yeah
pool and for everest specifically but on
k2 there was a funny story from years
previous where there was a russian
expedition a polish expedition and
they're very competitive with one
another and they literally were putting
ropes you know two feet beside the other
rope like this is the russian rope and
this is the polish rope and like
don't touch my rope kind of thing but we
you know very quickly that was like not
a thing and it was actually amazing like
there really was a deep sense of general
camaraderie um on this expedition
between the different teams different
climbers even though truly there was
just world-class climbers over there
people that i widely admire from around
the world and i didn't know what the
vibe was gonna be like and like it was
it was welcoming like it was we're
sharing cook tents we're having cups of
tea we're shooting the [ __ ] during the
storms like hanging out basically
um
and
uh
so nims who's obviously famous from the
14 peaks you know world record that he
set um in
2017 18 right eighteen eighteen eighteen
ten yeah um 2018. um and he brings his
same crew of guys that worked with him
that you know that he hired to help him
out with the other project some of the
most incredible climbers in the world
you know mingman david sherpa um you
know
uh
ming matenzing like so many of them
these guys are just like i mean such
amazing humans but also just uh
incredible climbers yeah and so they're
all over there and mad respect to them
they were pre-acclimatized when they got
there they got there a few days before
us on the track but were acclimatized
from being at the high altitude nepal
and then they just pushed really hard in
the first couple weeks we all thought
like this exhibition's going to take two
or three months for sure
we get there the you know
pose and generally the first of january
um and on january 12th i think it is
john and i are going up on a rotation up
the mountain to get to camp one maybe
sleep tonight at camp two and i'm up at
camp one um john's a little bit behind
me and i'm sitting down there with nims
and just the two of us some of his guys
are behind him you know he's waiting you
know this group group of them going up
and we're shooting the [ __ ] and they got
a lot of stuff with them and i'm like
kind of like
you guys
what's up man like you guys going for
the summit and he's kind of like nah
we're just you know we're trying to get
maybe we'll see if we get up to camp
three camp four you know like kind of
like like playing it playing it cool um
but like he's like yeah we'll see we'll
see um and you know honestly there's
there's been you know this is a shame
that always gets this way there's been
some criticism oh they didn't tell
people what they were doing or this that
and the other thing but like my take on
that their whole situation is
like mad respect like they
they pushed it they were there they were
there early there was a small weather
window and they took some significant
risk and ultimately there was a couple
other nepalese teams
that they colluded with ming magee who's
a world-class amazing climber but these
guys of course they they they they have
historically the nepalese sherpa nems
isn't a sherpa but the rest of them are
sherpas um
they have historically been a part of
other people's expeditions right so the
europeans get all their glory yeah
they're the they're always behind the
person right you know and it's amazing
and nims has had hugely positive
influence on this which is
you know allowing there to be more
access to nepalese
funded expeditions that aren't part of
a european or western portion of the
expeditions and like i said those guys
that i that i named before you know
mingman tenzing you know ming mcdavid
like these guys like these guys are
just world-class world-class climbers
like the benton there's nobody better
than those guys straight up and
they went for it and on january 16th um
a team of ten nepalese so six on nims's
team three on ming mcgene's team and one
um on on a separate team sona sherpa
they all made the summit of k2 and
claimed um that you know quote unquote
the last great prize in mountaineering
um and it made headlines across the
world yeah i think skullneck wrote uh i
think
new york times
um it was amazing like really truly
incredible and the way they did it was
after all these years of people spending
90 days over there and getting nowhere
like these dudes were there for three
weeks and you know they got the weather
but they went for it and they pushed it
and they made it to the top and like
they were singing the nepalese national
anthem carrying the flag on the summit
like it's a it's a proud moment and it's
crazy to think in all the history of of
mount of heil to mountaineering there
had never been a nepalese only first
ascent of a mountain um and so for these
guys to claim this really iconic ascent
and will forever be in the history books
um was amazing now but they got [ __ ] for
not communicating approp
again
there's it seems like there's a lot of
this there's
this unfortunately and it just it's it
really that's why to me i just lean into
the positive there's we could
deconstruct the whole thing of did they
tell the other people about the route
after we can get into some of their
stuff you want but like at the end of
the day like they got to the summit
january 16th 2021 10 nepalese summited
k2 and became the world first in this
ridiculously dangerous obscenely hard
climb
and in the middle dead of winter like
they did it no one can ever take that
away from them and like i'm certainly
not going to sit here and cast stones
like they did an incredible job now
john and i are on the mountain at this
point
because we had spent a night at camp 2
acclimatizing we were in no position to
climb we'd if we if we wanted to we were
not ready to go for the summit we needed
a couple more weeks to acclimatize get
our body get our camps higher stock etc
and we're descending down the mountain
so this route is ridiculously steep it's
a mix of ice and rock and snow um and
it's just it's basically eight thousand
feet straight up what's called the
abusive spur so you're basically on this
direct ridgeline so you can almost see
not the summit but you can see way high
up on the route is that where you're in
that video that i saw that's with one of
the qr codes where you're going up and
it's just like a sheer face and you have
the ropes yeah exactly exactly and one
of the things that was again we all took
this risk on which was
collectively there was there was some
new ropes placed on this route but
there's obviously old ropes from years
past but years past no one had been k2
in winter since a year and a half or
year and a half before that and summer
and so a lot of the sections because it
was so complicated and so cold and so
difficult to fix ropes we actually
clipped into old ropes which is like a
you know kind of cardinal sin in the
world of pile to mountaineering because
these ropes get beat up over time and
they're afraid and whatever was so
difficult to fix the route that there
was a lot of clipping into old ropes
that may or may not i mean there was a
lot of risk being risky being taken
and you know
when i think back on it i think
sometimes i think what the heck was i
thinking but you know eyes wide open we
took that risk on um and so john and i
are descending down that day again not
trying to weight the ropes with all of
our weight we're actually usually would
just like zip down on a rappel like on
going down because you trust your full
weight to the anchors the ropes we're
actually like down climbing we're
clipped into the ropes but we're down
climbing so just to not like if a rope
were to break or something like that we
might still be able to catch ourselves
kind of if that makes sense moving more
slowly and we can see some friends up
above in the route there's a spanish guy
sergey mingote his climbing partner jp
moore um
tamara longers you know they're above us
we can you can see so much on the route
and we finally descend back to what's
called advanced base camp so that's
where the fixed ropes ends and it's
about a three mile walk back to base
camp
and we um we we don't know if the net we
actually haven't heard yet that the
nepalese have summited and john and i
there's we're all decided since we're
colluding to be on an open radio channel
and so all the different teams just like
have a radio channel that we can all
communicate instead of being all
different including the nepalese yeah
everyone although obviously sometimes
john and i would switch to our own just
if we weren't trying to like crosstalk
everyone but there was a central channel
that everyone could be on and we would
hear like talking between you know if we
could reach anyone based on but it's
really common if you're really high and
the wind is blowing and they the
batteries die so not everyone is always
just in perfect radio communication
right but we had that but john and i for
whatever reason we said we get back down
to vase base camp there's been a lot of
chatter on the radio throughout that
whole day we just decided let's turn our
radios off just to like enjoy the peace
and calm of this walk this three-mile
glacier walk back to camp
so we get back into camp and as we're
walking back that takes a couple hours
we get back down to camp again we had
seen the climbers up above us when we
were going we get back down to camp
and all of a sudden there's all these
banging of pots and pans
like a celebration and nims is base camp
manager the nepalese team base camp
manager was like they summoned it they
summoned it they're up there right now
it's 5 p.m at night like they did it and
john and i like look at each other and
again like for me like people always ask
you must been so frustrated you're
trying to get this world first whatever
like honestly of course there's some
general competition and we all wanted to
be the first or whatever but like there
was no better people to get this summit
these were the guys that were the most
deserving the most talented the best
like they deserved so we were just like
wow heck yeah like wow they pulled it
off and in style like let's just hope
they get down safe you know
and so like there's this momentary hive
like they did it the nepalese summit
banging pots and pans and literally one
minute later
there's a pakistani military official
there um it's called a liaison officer
who's kind of like overseeing base camp
to make sure like no one's like
polluting the area it's also in a
military you're in a military zone that
you're right on the afghanistan border
you're on some kind of like intense sort
of border areas and so it's just kind of
like making sure nothing weird is going
on just literally lives in base camp and
just kind of like hangs out and he steps
out of his
uh tent
and he's like
sergi just fell he's dead
and we were like like literally like in
one minute like the nepalese summited
sergi just fell like he's dead
um and john and i were like no that
can't be like we just saw him he was
just right up above us like that was a
couple hours ago whatever and it turns
out just a few minutes after john and i
had turned off our radio to walk back
just above us um no one knows exactly
what happened whether it was a rope that
broke or more than likely he was
climbing a section unroped and slipped
but sergey mangote was literally one of
the best best climbers in the world you
know hit this moment he was you know
seven mountains in to setting the speed
record of the fourteen eight thousand
meter peaks like dams but with no
supplemental oxygen
truly truly a world-class um guy and
just an amazing guy literally our tents
were right beside each other in base
camp i'd see him every single morning
chat with him and just in an instant
like the both the triumph of k2 and the
just the unrelenting danger of k2 boom
in sharp focus and he's dead um it bears
noting that in summer there's been i'm
going to get the numbers exactly right
but you know 350-ish successful summits
of this mountain um but it's claimed 85
lives again give or take those numbers
but essentially there's a 25 fatality
rate on k2 summits per that and that's
in summer and morocco how does that mesh
with everest
oh everest is like two percent or
something like that three percent so i
mean everest is very dangerous
but it's yeah i mean k2 is widely
considered the most dangerous mountain
in the world in the best of
circumstances but it was a crazy thing
because like the nepalese on a summit
push at the top of the mountain are
there and they're safe and sergey
mingote again also one of the best
climbers in the world
on a
on basically back to base camp
makes us you know just right boom small
air boom he falls juxtaposition of those
two things and the fact that you had
just seen him yeah i mean we've just
been right there um and so
obviously that hit all of us heavy and
there was just this there was this
interesting
um
dual energy in base camp at this moment
the the nepalese success rightfully so
was such a big deal globally but
particularly in central asia
in pakistan in in in nepal etc that the
they were as they should have been
treated like kings the the head of the
pakistani military shows up in a
helicopter to fly them out of there and
to throw celebrations for them at the
like military palace or whatever these
10 nepalese are getting you know
festivals in the streets of kathmandu
you know it's an incredible celebration
this i will never forget the same moment
that that helicopter landed with the
pakistani military general um
i helped carry sergi's buddy body which
was wrapped up in a sleeping bag
into a helicopter right beside it and so
there was just this like dual
right
thing happening in this moment the dark
and the light yeah um it was really
intense and you know i i've had
proximity to some other
you know deaths and things on on everest
and some other places i've climbed but
a little bit further detached like not
like people i was like oh there was a
guy in another team where someone passed
on this day or when i summoned it in
2016 my first ever suscept people had
died that day but not when anybody in
hawaii had ever known you know i'd seen
a dead body like frozen but had been up
there for 10 years but this was like
this is a guy i was hanging out with
like just the other day and like boom
like gone
um
and there was definitely a question in
that moment
is this expedition over like the world
first is gone
and sergi just died like
but we had only been there for three
weeks and we'd all planned to be there
for three months like the whole winter
basically and so i remember talking to
jenna what was your memory of that that
moment i mean it was just it was
because the media was obviously showing
showcasing so much about the celebration
and the accomplishment which of course
should have been like the focus right
it was a hard reality because i'm
sitting there you know
knowing how gut-wrenching i mean i i met
sergi i had many teas with him and meals
and conversations throughout our time in
base camp and it was just like a hugely
positive humble gentle kind loving
family man i mean really he was that's
what he talked about his wife and his
kids and
um it was just it was hard it was the
first time i mean certainly the first
person i ever knew personally that had
passed away on a mountain um and so and
you know when colin's trying to figure
out dr john should they stay should they
not
there was definitely moments where i
wanted to raise my hand and be like just
come home like what are you doing like
just come home like it we're good
and was that conversation when you were
hacking it up with posner and the cinder
block you know ice box or was it later
when you kind of got further down it was
later yeah we were back just a couple
days yeah yeah something like you guys
got home on the 13th or 14th and then
this happened on the 16th so she had
just gotten home like like it taken her
two weeks yeah yeah yeah it hadn't been
long like you basically just got back
home but you were definitely home i
remember talking to you you were at home
when i called you on zappone i was just
crying so hard you had to be like yeah
like what am i doing yeah like sergey is
dead in terms like are you sure i'm like
we're sure like he's dead like
you know i was just like and then
yeah i remember
something that sticks with me from that
moment is like i said his tent was right
beside mine in base camp literally right
next to each other and i just remember
waking up that morning and like
that tense being packed down and that's
gone his body's there it's just like
this very like final final yeah i know
he had three kids at home anyway so we
do decide to stay i mean and ultimately
like you can go back and forth about
that decision but it was like
we came here the expectation was being
here for months it's been three weeks
the net police crushed it so fast like
it was just like had it been the end of
february or something like that we'd all
been there for two months and we were
strung out and like all this kind of
stuff and this happened had been like
this is over someone just died these
guys summoned at this peak but like it
wasn't like that like it was like well
uh you know like emotionally we all just
like had planned to be there we had
supplies to be there for a longer period
of time and so we were like and if
nothing else
they just proved it was possible
like they you're right like there's
something about that again it's not like
you know if your ego can let go of the
world first like and again like for me
it's like well i just want to challenge
myself against this mountain so it's
like and they just showed the whole
world like it actually can be done they
just did it and there's hypothetically
some ropes up there now and like that
like there's a way to do this so like
john and i decide to stay um a couple
people left but the majority of people
stayed including
um
jp moore who was sergey's climbing
partner um so sergey's climbing partner
was a chilean guy by the name of j.p
moore incredible guy um and i remember
giving him a hug as we were loading that
body in the helicopter and i just
assumed he was getting on the helicopter
like he was he was gonna gonna go home
and he's like i think i'm gonna stay i'm
gonna summit this mountain for sergey um
and
you know
jp
was also one of the as was sergi one of
the purest climbers in the high altitude
mountaineering world which is they were
climbing with
they were sharing the ropes with
everyone else but other than that they
were using no
no
no supporter support no one else was
carrying anything for them ever even on
the lower part of the mountain he was
using no supplemental oxygen like the
purists and he had done everest lotsy
without suffering yeah he had a record
forever
of supplemental supplement oxygen he has
this incredible climate of annapurna
without supplement oxygen which is that
and k2 are like kind of in parity for
ridiculously stupidly dangerous risk
taking mountains um
and what ends up happening is after this
there's a three two or three week long
storm
um and we get like really hunkered down
in base camp like can't move kind of
thing like just getting blasted things
just sit in these tents yeah just
kidding 12 hours just sit there all day
long
just like literally and what ended up
happening is that like a nightmare jp
decides to team up with this no part of
it yeah it's really uncomfortable it's
extremely uncomfortable and there's you
know every morning the ice is like caked
in the inside of your tent from your
breath freezing it and then you sit up
in this ice it's minus 30 and the ice
just drops on your head inside of your
like clothes it's and that's a base camp
so the base camp of k2 in winter
was the equivalent temperature minus 30
minus 40 of what the summit of everest
normally is on a summit day in the
summer so that's that's just and so
usually you're tapping into that for a
few hours on a summit push or something
like that this is day in day out at base
camp let alone looking at like we're
seeing weather forecasts like oh 150
mile per hour winds 120 minus 120 wind
chill stuff like that we're like
watching the weather it's just like
icicles yeah it's like that's a no-go
that's a no-go
we see it start trending back towards oh
it's only minus 70. we might be able to
go for it
and it's now it's early february
and we had dumped some
actually spent a ton of time me dr john
has spent a ton of time with jp because
we actually kind of combined into one
dining tent during this long wait when
he and when sergey had passed away and
so we had spent a lot of time with him
over those couple of weeks and a bunch
of the other climbers were in a
different diet not that we didn't see
people we spent like a ton of time like
you know 15 hours a day in this tent
with jp and this woman tamara who her
climbing partner had left um and so the
two of them decided to team up to to
climb and sergi's honor
so the weather window is approaching and
the same thing of course everyone's
looking at the same weather so
everyone's thinking like well if we're
going to go this is it again not
climbing together not like oh we're
going to leave at the same time and this
but it's like pretty obvious like i'm
going to go on this day you're going to
go on this day like that's the way it's
going to work out
and
a couple of climbers who didn't feel
that's physically strong left on
february 2nd
to go to camp 1 for the night but john
and i decided to kind of save our energy
and to leave on the morning of february
third and climb directly to camp two so
there's usually four camps on cape town
above advanced base camp
but we all including following the
nepalese lead they didn't use a camp
four so they summoned it from camp three
meaning way longer summit push and we're
like well this weather window's so short
it's middle winter this is probably too
hard to set up camp for so let's you
know use their blueprint now and only
use where camp three is and then try to
do a long push from there so we're
analyzing all the weather and john and i
think okay let's climb directly to camp
two
sleep there on the third of february go
to camp three on the fourth and then the
morning of the fifth was supposed to be
like this clearing window and like i
said clearing is in it's minus 60 with
50 mile per hour winds for like a half a
day before just you know 100 miles per
hour once again three push to summit
yeah exactly um and so we're leaving we
we
middle of the night we're climbing um i
remember right officers leave base camp
a couple climbers pass us a guy named
ali sabara who's uh like the michael
jordan of pakistan he's like just a
legendary climber in pakistan some he
has a first ascent of nanga parbat in
winter what's one of the first winter
ascents that he did um and an icelandic
guy named john snory and his son sajid
they pass us on the lower mountain
and john and i are just kind of plotting
away and we get up just above advanced
base camp we're just clipped into the
ropes we're only like maybe 200 feet
really up onto the route it's like
starting to get steep but it's the very
beginning of the route
and
dr john looks over at me he's been
climbing in front of me i've been behind
him by i don't know 10 feet or something
like that and he looks back at me and
he's just he's got a tear in his eyes
and he's like i'm turning around man
and i was like what like what
and he's like
i'm just there's just like an intuition
that if i he says to me straight point
blank he says if i keep going i feel i'm
gonna die up there like i need to turn
around
and
it was a very arresting moment of course
um
but john and i actually jenna
facilitated a conversation in moab
actually because we have been in moab
where we have been living for that
period time
and you that's what you said to us you
said let's have yeah so we john lives in
colorado and he came out to moab to
visit
and this was at the time when colin was
thinking about doing this project and i
really
i really wanted to call him to climb
with someone who he felt really
comfortable with who he knew who was
familiar with as a climbing partner that
they could both entrust in each other
and trust in each other's individual
decision making and
so the first person that popped in my
mind was dr john so dr john came out and
kind of just sat down with colin and
john and just said hey like i want to
hear from both of you individually how
you're thinking about this john if
you're interested
how we would go about making decisions
and and it was a beautiful conversation
around
you know if if either one of them at any
point in time felt like it wasn't the
right decision to keep going
they could leave the leave the
expedition
no harm no foul and it would be on the
other person to decide if they wanted to
choose to keep going and one of the
things that was important that you said
to us is jenna like jenner like really
set us both down
and said let's have all of the
conversations about all the scenarios
right now at sea level not in the heat
of the moment and whatever decision we
decide here
whatever happens up on the mountain
we're gonna know that we thought about
this with completely lucid clear and i
could remind them from seeing the sea
level of what the decision was yeah and
then there's there's sort of the
intellectual exercise of doing that
versus the reality of being in that
moment and the pressure
well you're just afraid right now we can
push through like what is what is you
know the difference between that gut
instinct that's telling you this is
wrong i need to back out versus like
well this is a little scary but like
let's just keep going you know and
overcome that fear totally and i think
you know i think that
you know knowing that where that line is
and we both knew how dangerous this
mountain was even before sergey pass
we're like this is a massive risk just
going over there like we're risking our
lives like for sure and there have been
a lot of rock fall like i've been hit
we've both gotten hit by rocks uh
another climber got hit in the head by
the rocks and split open like a huge
like gash on his face like there's rocks
like literally it sounds like dude it's
all bad yeah it's just a bat like it's
like flying past our head we'd be like
do we like we'd yell at you rock me like
jump out of the way and like on my drone
flying past our head while rocking
like and that would happen 50 times a
day kind of thing i mean
there's rocks i mean it's just it's very
dangerous and um
so when john looked at me with this tear
in his eyes i went right back to this
moment in moab where it was like we
looked at each other as brothers and
said
this is not the moment on this mountain
to say come on man you know suck it up
like whatever it was just like it was
heart-wrenching um yeah you mentioned
there's there's a at the end of the
chapter on this in the book the qr code
i have a little video clip of this
moment that i yeah it's filmed pretty
powerful and video i'm crying but he
says to me just very he says colin like
dude i've been watching you for the last
six weeks like you're on form right now
he's just like you're climbing like he's
like objectively friend a friend like
you're climbing very well right now
if you feel like you can go emotionally
like you're ready like you can do this
so he wasn't really was not trying to
get me to back off he was just saying
like something's not right for me man
but i'm watching you and like you seem
like you can do this like you sh if you
want to go for it like go for it like i
support you like 100 like go for it
and it's so cold it's so freaking cold
you stand still for five minutes and
your fingers and toes start to freeze so
it's not like hey let's sit here and
discuss this for an hour it's like
within one you know within a few minutes
john's headed back down and i've decided
to keep climbing up because you can't
stand there and like debate it for into
the ground
and i'm alone on the mountain um
everyone else had left before so i'm the
lowest person on the mountain at this
point and we john and i had been
climbing
um with two sherpas one by the name of
ming temba and one by the main of excuse
me um uh lok potemba and ming temba um
and they had been a little bit higher on
the mountain so i got on the radio with
them and i said hey john's turning
around i'm still gonna come up they're
like okay we're near camp two uh we'll
wait for you here and we'll we'll see
you up here when you get there and so i
end up um in camp two uh sharing a tent
with ming temba and lok patemba uh who
have been high on the mountain and you
know i get into bed it's camp two that
night and i'm tired and afraid and all
the things but also kind of like okay
like i am feeling good like i'm feeling
great so i wake up the following morning
and leave camp two um and i'm chatting
with ming tembo and lok patemba and i'm
just like i'm like all right well let's
all meet up at camp three i'm thinking
we're gonna like you know climb together
or whatever but like you know i'm just
gonna i'm just gonna head off now um and
so i start climbing
and
the next six hours like quite honestly
between cam 2 and cam 3 is the most
dangerous part and
that or arguably the most dangerous part
of the entire route is this part called
the black pyramid there's another part
called the bottleneck near the summit
that's also very dangerous but the black
pyramid is probably the most technically
complicated part of the mountain it's
called mixed climbing so it's
tons of rock exposed rock huge exposure
seven eight thousand feet ice snow rock
fall it's just a complex kind of
section
and very very steep and direct given how
high you are you're at 20 3000 24 000
feet at this point
and
i had the best day of climbing in my
entire life like just purely flow state
tapped in just feeling it like i just
like everything felt effortless i felt
smooth i felt strong
and i end up kind of just getting into
my own rhythm i passed jp and tomorrow
who had been a little bit higher where
they were camping and i end up being all
alone in the black pyramid by myself
climbing up on k2 in winter and there's
no one else above me on the mountain so
i'm completely alone up there and i'm
feeling great honestly um i don't i
actually can't remember a time on a
mountain anyways i can remember a time
in antarctica tapping into the same sort
of essence but like on a mountain that's
like just like just felt in rhythm the
fear wasn't there um you know following
the the some of the fixed routes that
have been fixed ropes that have been
laid as well as some of these older
ropes skipping into but just like was
was in it
and end up like way high up on the
mountain
approaching where i think cam 3 is but
i've never been to camp three before at
this point camp two is my highest on the
acclimatization so i was on a new part
of the mountain that i hadn't seen
before and all of a sudden the fixed
rope that had been that have been placed
with anchors all of a sudden it just
disappears like it it's buried into the
under the ground and someone's thinking
oh it's no drift i need to try to dig it
out or something like that but i can't
find like where the next section of the
route goes and there's crevasses
everywhere and when you're alone and
you're not roped together and on a fixed
rope like being alone on a glacier is
super dangerous for the express reason
of like usually a rope to a partner so
if you were to fall into a crevasse
someone else can like pull you out to
walking around on a crevasse part of a
mountain any mountain let alone 23 000
24 000 feet on k2 in winter by yourself
is just like a [ __ ] terrible idea
like this all-time bad idea
and so um i kind of like what should i
do what should i do i don't think i can
sit here for that long because it's so
cold but i really have anything else i
can do and so i just sit down
i sit down
and i think okay i've got my radio i've
got my stat phone like let me try to get
in contact john's back in base camp at
this point so i pull up my radio to call
dr john and all of a sudden the wind
hits my radio boom it goes blank
radio's dead oh [ __ ]
um and then i i send this text or i have
this so i have my sat phone i try to get
on my sat phone and to call jenna
and sat phone same thing
in the wind it's dead
and the last thing i have is this little
it's called a garmin inreach which can
like send these like just like basic
text message like type of thing and i
get this cryptic text
and it says i'm all alone up here i
don't know where anyone is and i was
planning to send like five follow-ups to
that
that goes out
to jenna
and then
it dies
oh i'm like
uh okay like where where do you think
you are
pick up your radio call john call anyone
no
no replies
so i'm like freaking out oh my god like
what is happening where i have no idea
where i mean i can see so different than
everest the satellite tracker actually
tracks pretty accurately on k2 for
whatever reason i don't know if it's the
the mountains in the way or something
but the the tracker was pinging all over
the place so i was like i actually
couldn't get it
and she can it looks like i might be
over here i might be over there now i'm
not responding the last text she gets
from me is she can see because it
geolocates when you send a text out it
like gives you a lat launch position so
she can see that position but it's me
like somewhere ish on the route saying
i'm all alone i don't know where anyone
is i'm this like and maybe this is a
dumb question but why didn't you for
that particular push have somebody join
you like why were you why did you make
the decision to try to do that alone so
like i said like when i left camp crazy
yeah i left camp and you know i've been
like chatting with ming temba and lok
patemba and was like all right let's all
leave and they're like oh we're just
gonna like they were just like oh yeah
we're coming in ten minutes like it was
just like it was one of those things
where it's like looking back obviously
like
there was some communication like i
thought you would be this like loose
group yeah like wear each other yeah and
it's like such challenging terrain that
you think like
i might take a break this person's gonna
catch up jp's higher like people are out
like you know what i mean you just kind
of assumed that that was what was gonna
happen and so rather than like all
standing around the corner it's so cold
so standing around and waiting for five
or ten minutes if someone's like oh i
still need to grab this for my backpack
whatever it's like oh i should just
start walking to get myself warmed up so
it's that that's why the decision that
decision was made and again i just i had
a good day like i climbed well i was
climbing in flow and
people were a little slower than me or
whatever um on that day i mean there's
plenty of days where i wasn't the
fastest but that day i was the fastest
and so i ended up just you know getting
even more alone basically
um and so
that happens and i sit there for an hour
and a half on my backpack trying to
think what to do and i finally see a
climber in the distance approaching in a
bright yellow suit and i think oh that's
or that's ming temba great
so i wait another like half hour
everyone's moving so slow you know you
can see somebody for a long time before
they approach because it's like every
step is so hard earned
and finally um
figures approaching and i realized like
oh
it's not ming temba it's jp
and i'm thinking like oh okay it's jp i
wonder where tamara is because he had
been climbing with her before and i had
passed him he's you know he's he's
again pure no supplemental auction
nothing and he approaches me and we have
this big warm embrace and i'm like
what's going on like where's tamara like
how are you feeling he's like usually i
mean he literally is the strongest
climber i've ever met my entire life and
he's like
my feet are pretty cold man but like i
think we're looking back she she thinks
she's gonna turn back and i'm gonna keep
going
um
and i'm like well
like camp 3 is somewhere right by here
but i don't know where it is and he had
never been on this part of k2 before
neither of us this was new for both of
us
and
he's like
well
i guess we need to climb this section
unroped like we need to like climb this
unroped or maybe we can figure something
out but he was just like super
determined and a credit where credit's
due like i was i was kind of stopping my
tracks having another partners like well
we could rope together we could do
something here that's a little bit you
know basically a little bit safer but it
was like all right like we're going to
be stepping on the edge and you know
again to fast forward the story but
basically me him and then lockwood and
ming temba caught up to us not that long
after that and a slovenian guy named
thomas thomas ratar all of us over the
next 30 minutes or an hour or something
like that time's a little bit
wishy-washy in my brain on that moment
climbed through this section unroped um
and threw these glaciers to reach um
which is just consequential i mean it's
high consequence every step is like high
consequence if you slip there no rope
like you're flying down 8 000 feet like
falling or crevassed you're you're in a
bad spot but we think camp 3 is pretty
close and it turns out it's only about
100 vertical feet from where we've been
so like we get up over this next little
sort of plateau and it's like oh wow
like that's where it was so i was
sitting just below camp two for like or
camp three for several hours at this
point but now the sun's going down now
it's getting dark
and my whole point was like i wanna get
to camp three get inside my tent melt
some water i'm gonna put on dry socks
and really just resting for like three
or four hours and then we're gonna climb
through the night from camp three all
the way to the summit push it's a way
station it's not like camp three set up
have a nice long sleep or anything like
that it's just like a reset it's almost
like i think about like an aid station
or something like that and like an ultra
event like you're like i'm gonna be here
for a few hours make sure all my my gear
is tightened up i have the bare bones
that i need and that's where we're gonna
go so we get inside our tent jp has this
tiny little like basically a one-man
tank barely fit two people inside of it
there
we have a three-man tent still very
small we get inside
and the sun's setting and we're thinking
well other climbers some of people
weren't quite as strong they must have
turned around they must have turned
around because it's dark now and we're
trying to summit that night and we're
coming from camp three we're thinking
like well they must have turned around
the one other person that was there at
this point was ali sabara this pakistani
guy that i mentioned before and he had
been climbing this icelandic guy and he
goes my son and john snorri they're not
far behind and we're thinking these guys
are super strong too spring okay they're
coming but there must surely these ten
other people that have been climbing
some point in the black pyramid when it
got dark have turned around like this is
turned around for sure
and then as we're trying to get the
stove lit and trying to get things going
i start hearing voices outside and i'm
like what wow other people are arriving
crazy like they're still pushing for it
like i was just like really surprised
because it just seemed like the margin
of error at this point had like got
expired kind of if you were still out
there climbing
and then i hear this
kind of this rustling and people being
like [ __ ] [ __ ] what do you have the tent
do i
look in your bag look at my bag
it turned out
10 people arrived
and there was confusion over who was
carrying their various tents and it
turns out they have no tents
it's dark
24 000 feet on k2 in winter and there
there's 10 people now outside with no
tents oh my god
how does that happen like
i mean do a post-mortem and like i said
it's like not really in this like i i
really i haven't talked about then i
wrote a chapter about this on the book
but in the year plus after this like
i've really taught not spoken publicly
much about this whole situation because
it's just been such a heartbreaker for
me uh i think i'm finally ready to kind
of talk about it a little bit more but
it they made a mistake i mean there's
good point fingers at a million
different people but the the the long
story short is they arrived at camp
three with no tents
no tents so a guy pops his head into my
tent and he's like he's like hey man
like we're out here like we have no
tents like can we come inside and like
well of course i'm not gonna like let
these guys like freeze like out there in
this tents like by themselves
and so i let um as many people as can
fit into my tent before i know it
there's seven people inside of my tent
seven people in a three-man tent three
men tents really a two-man tent like and
like yeah they're very liberal with how
many people can get in these yeah
especially
yeah so you get this huge gear backpacks
like ice axe i mean the whole deal and
now a sudden there's seven people inside
my tent and i am in like a fetal
position
and i can't even get down to my boots to
unzip my boots and put on dry socks
we're having a hard time like there's
not enough stoves not enough water like
it's just like the wheels are like
falling off and then the other tent
across from me was ali said partisan he
had been in my tent waiting for john
snory but they their tent had arrived
and the same thing happened so now
there's r210s and that was like a a
two-person tent right so jp's was even
smaller there's any there's three tents
now there's jp's like tiny tiny tiny
like it's like a base like a mummy sack
little tent and tamara ends up coming
and joining him then there's this other
tent the two three man tents basically
now each of them have six seven people
like inside of them and have to think
really hard to get the exact but seven
ish seven there's almost eight in mine
because there's like seven in mind
they're like one guy sitting in the
vestibule on the snow but at least a
little bit out of the wind like it's
like
dire situation
and i get on the radio um
and
so i wore my radio back up inside my
tent on the stove i warm the battery
back up and i can get it working again
and i call down to john and explain the
situation and john i mean i love that
guy's one of my you know just my soul
soul family um
but he has this like calm demeanor like
he's just a very calm optimistic
positive guy and he i'm like like i'm
like bro this is [ __ ] like this is a
bad situation he's like colin i know
you're going through a tough spot but
like he's just like really trying to
calm me down like doing it's like he's
like you still have a shot to go for the
summit like the weather's gonna hold but
you need to leave soon like and i'm like
i don't think you know how bad this is
then i went on the open channel
on the radio
and i said um i said
this is a bad situation like people are
gonna die out here i think people are
gonna die out here i'm saying this i
know that everyone like can hear me like
people are up here without tents like
i'm like this is a bad like a bad deal
and please tell me you called jenna yeah
leaving jenna hanging with that text
message well i didn't hear from him
right away but i did reach out to john
so john was back in base camp and i was
like john you gotta get some information
like i'm
at the end of the road right now like
this is not good i i need some calm and
luckily he is exactly as calm and
described like very calming and very
reassuring and he had heard from colin
on the radio so i still hadn't heard
from colin at this point until just
after this yeah and so
i did you know i reached i reached out
to jenna
um on the sat phone in this moment as
well so i got that go back and going um
and like i said i've been yelling i've
been yelling and through this radio like
i was i was like this is a bad deal was
a weird thing because it's like
of course there's not a one percent of
me that was like leave these guys
outside you know they messed up like of
course i mean that's just like that's
just like common human ethic like of
course you need to be coming inside but
it's also clear it's very obvious that
eight people crammed in my tent before
i'm trying to put a summit push together
for k2 in winter is like the worst case
scenario in terms of my own preparation
like no rest no sleep no not proper
hydration not like all the things that i
had like planned to do were like
very yeah things are not lining up
optimally no um
and
so i you know i called to jenna i mean i
called home i called to jenna um
and uh yeah interesting to hear tell me
tell me what you remember from that
moment yeah i mean he sounded distressed
like quite distressed and i asked him
where he was so i actually at this point
knew that he was at camp three in a tent
um but my memory i just remember you
saying i mean you were upset crying
um
and you you just said
i
am trying to make a decision on if i
should continue going up or not or if i
should call it and stop here and
you know colin calls me in in a lot of
critical moments on everest in different
situations and asked me for my opinion
and
in this specific instance i really
didn't have a good read on the situation
like that that last cryptic test text
message was less i'd heard from him
i couldn't communicate fluidly with
anyone on the mountain and i i really
didn't have like a gut feeling i was
just i felt
kind of like removed from the situation
which in other situations i felt very
connected and very intuitively tapped in
and this i just i didn't really know and
so i i mean i think i said
colin i don't have a good read on this
one and i trust you and i need you to
make this decision and and now is the
time like the time had been taking on
and i knew what the projected departure
time was if he was going to actually
make a summit attempt
and it was ticking on and it was beyond
the time at which yeah you were
basically gone you're basically saying
remember you said trust your intuition
but you also said but whatever you need
to do you actually need to make a
decision right now like the yeah you're
gonna miss
you're gonna walk into a storm if you
like don't leave soon basically yeah and
i think in more of like a heightened way
it was like make the decision now like
make the call like i need you to
actually
make this call like i can't see what
you're seeing right now but one thing
that's interesting reflecting just when
you said we've had this other intense
moment there's like five other calls
that like went into my head like the
first day in antarctica that moment on
occur with the food my first everest
descent when i got caught out in a
massive storm like i've called jenna
from some really rough spots and most of
the time if not every other time she has
helped me prob like reminded me like
you're the guy who does hard things like
you can do this like go inside of
yourself tap into your inner strength
power i mean she has pushed me in
environments that are
implicitly risky and challenging like
she hasn't been like the no i definitely
am not the one who always had you ever
told him like no you need to pull the
plug like definitively like that's my
gut
um
that's a good question or was it always
a dig deeper i actually think it's
mostly ben
you can do this i believe in you or a
problem solved like uh like hey if
you're gonna do this here like let's
talk about the like let's think about
that right so it's funny you know i've
i've
i've shared those other not this story
but other stories people and they're
like oh my partner would have told me to
just come home yeah you know crazy yeah
why are you living up there in the first
place you didn't sleep yeah really
dangerous and you're not gonna do what
everyone else does which is then take
another break at camp two you're gonna
push straight through like this doesn't
it
sounds like a bad deal you know but to
jenna was like i remember just saying
like i don't have a read on this but you
got to make a call trust your intuition
so then there's two tents everyone's
crammed in there so i can talk to
everyone in there but there's also the
other tent like we just you know
verbally we can talk to each other
because they're right next to each other
and i'm kind of thinking like what do
you what's everyone doing you know kind
of taking
the temperature check of everyone
and there's a collective like we're
going for it like for the most part
there was a couple people i mean but
like most people were like oh yeah this
is fine this isn't that big of a deal we
weren't really gonna sleep here anyways
like just all the justifications why
this with no tents at camp three like
wasn't really still made sense that's
significant in k2 in winter um
and
you know a lot of people were like oh
well you know i always thought this was
i thought this was a little bit of an
interesting calculus but a lot of people
were like well the nepalese took this
long to summit from here and then was 15
or 16 hours or something like that and
they're gauging their time based off
this in the back of my mind i'm thinking
with david sherpa is the strongest human
being i have ever met and it took him 16
hours like i would never put myself in
that category let alone meet some of
these other people like you know maybe
someone like a jp but he's climbing
without supplemental oxygen or something
like that you're just going like people
were like oh so you know 15 16 hours
we're still within the thing and i'm
like
okay but you know it's interesting
calculus but there was a collective
we're going for it
and
ali sapara someone who again i've really
admired from a long time from afar and
then became friends on this trip and
he'd summoned nanga parpat and winter at
first ascent
was talking with him was like
what what's what's your guys's call like
i kind of was tuning everyone else out
but like this guy like dialed dialed of
all dialed has made a first ascent in
winter in pakistan like what's your read
on this and he was like dude we're going
like we are for sure going colin climb
with us like we're gonna make the summit
man i'm like you got here before all of
us you're climbing so strong like let's
go like let's go and he's just saying
this he's like most cheery optimistic
smiling like joy-filled human and even
in this intense moment like his enjoy
this joy was was infectious like just
kind of like he's like this i know this
feels bad but you know the expeditions
they always get hard at some point and
this is the moment where you got to kind
of like push through
and
i end up closing my eyes i'm going like
okay i got to make this decision i gotta
make it soon but i gotta check in with
myself and i'm lying in a fetal position
basically he's crammed in the edge of my
tent i closed my eyes and i don't really
know how long i closed the eyes for but
it was a significant period of time
released from memory
and i just went deep inside of myself
and
my intuition my gut voice was loud and
clear
can you hear me yeah i can hear you
i decided not to go up
it was like
you got to get home to jenna and jack
jack's my dog
you you got to get home to jenna and
jack i just like feeling that mantra was
kind of building up inside of me i was
like whoa like my voice is telling me
to turn around
and before i express that out loud to
anybody else i did i kind of went
through the check in my brain which was
like okay but now play this out if
you're quitting right now and these guys
are going
now imagine them getting to the summit
being successful and we're all gonna be
back down in base camp like three days
later it's an ego check and you're the
only one pulling out right as opposed to
a split in the group right like going
like i literally did this i like
actually visualized in this kind of
meditative whatever deep moment looking
inward moment i looked inside on
something i was like well of course you
want everyone to be safe here you want
everyone to succeed i'm not i'm not it's
not my personality like cheer against
somebody's like whatever especially the
stakes being so high so i'm like okay so
picture that they go
you weren't whatever badass enough to
leave the tent you turn around and two
days later these guys make the summit to
you know all this
global acclaim in the mountaineering
community for this amazing second ascent
of k2 and winter and all this kind of
stuff and like you were right there you
were climbing well your body's strong
you can do it john your pro climbing
partner is telling you you can do it
yeah
exactly simple as that
and still i'll be honest
i was i felt
and i haven't felt this way really in in
this high-tech high-stakes situation i
felt at peace like i really like that i
just there was actually this full
relaxation of my muscles and my in my
being in this fetal position where i
just went like
oh like i feel like i could breathe for
the first time i was like i'm not going
and i i i say to the other guys there i
say to ali i said
i'm not going and no one tried no like
you know there'd been a little bit of
like come on man like let's go whatever
but once that they knew like i was like
i'm not going and they were like all
right like we're leaving like we're
going
and and then you gotta get back down by
yourself without anyone else yeah so i
so the following i i said i'm gonna but
i'm gonna stay here until morning
because february fifth morning's
supposed to be great weather so like i'm
not gonna try to move at night you
people are gonna leave this tent's gonna
be more empty
um
lockpotemba who i had been climbing with
still says to me well like i want to
climb even though him and i were
supposed to you know he was helping
support my climb he asked me he said
well do you mind if i still go and i was
like dude like of course like he
actually made the summit was going to be
the only person to have ever submitted
k2 four times he submitted three times
before in summer he watched his you know
fellow nepalese just summit in winter
and all this and he was like he was
still motivated and people were going
like people were like we're going
and i was like i'm not going and
it was a long night it was a hard night
people left and a bunch of
masks broke actually in the next few
hours people that were using
supplemental oxygen not everyone but a
bunch including loch batemba um
oxygen masks
failed from the cold
because i mean again this is a
temperature that like no one's ever
really climbing in it's not like this
stuff's not you know you think it's you
know it's tested to minus 40 but it's
different than minus 70 or whatever who
knows but several peoples including
sajid sappara
who is ali sabara's 21 year old son
he had a failure of his oxygen mask and
so a bunch of people um
had to turn around in the next three or
so three to five hours because of some
technical difficulties and some people
started getting too cold and and some
people did turn around
um
but the
the strongest amongst the group which
was jp ali zappara and john snorri
kept climbing they kept climbing towards
the summit and so the sun comes up
i don't know exactly what time sunrise 7
a.m 8 a.m something like that and i
finally get outside of my tent some
people have returned
different stories whatever but people
had gone for it there's some people with
some like little bits of frostbite and
things like that but you know not
everyone had kept going for the summit
and they'd said well those three are
still up there
weather might be turning i don't know
when we last saw them maybe they're
turning around it's unclear but like
they're still going for it and so i
remember like well i was like well i'm
going back down
and i talked to some other folks and
wish them well and i talked to my friend
the bulgarian climber atanas
and he had gone out that night and he
had gotten tripped up and he turned
around and i said well i'll see you back
down at base camp like you know what
what a crazy thing we all just
experienced the weather's pretty good
right now let's all get down safely clip
every rope and i'll see you in base camp
and we'll you know have a have a tea and
a beer maybe or something like that and
just like you know kind of relive what a
crazy moment this was but just kind of
like you know save positive vibes
and some blessings yeah kind of count
our blessings and it was actually a
really beautiful moment there was like
such a clear calm like one few is clear
because of the summit push moment so
it's clear calm i took these pictures
with atana standing there and i decide
and i start climbing down and i'm
climbing down um similar you know
sequence the way i had climbed up in
front of other people i left camp before
everyone else and so i'm climbing down
um by myself
and i get back down towards camp two
and i hear a bunch of like chatter like
on the radio but it's in uh so urdu and
the sherpa nepalese language they
actually are able to understand one
another even though it's different
obviously language and dialects they can
communicate pretty well but the the
staff in the base camp is mostly
pakistani and then up on the mountains
mostly nepalese um the mix of both but
mostly i hear a bunch of chatter
obviously i can't like understand it and
understand any of it and i get back down
to camp two i'm waiting for a little bit
and i see ming temba
and
he looks at me and he's like oh
something something's very wrong some
things like happen and he says
uh
atanos just fell
and i was like really i was just with
him he's like i think so but i'm not
sure there's a lot of crosstalk on the
radio it's a little bit unclear but
we're hearing something is not right
he's like get down safe and i'm like now
i'm like so locked and i'm actually
starting to say out loud to myself i'm
like i've got to get home to jenna and
jack i've got to get home to jenna i'm
like saying it out loud of every single
rope i'm clipping and now i'm down to
this lower part of the mountain between
camp 2 and advanced base camp where you
can see all the way down the route and
i'm alone and i'm descending and i'm
trying to again kind of down climb
because i'm on some of these old frayed
ropes and my nerves are just completely
shot at this point i'm just saying focus
focus i actually in my in my head i
remember telling myself
he must have misheard
atanos didn't fall he must have missed
her i'm like that's i told myself that
just folding up antanas was not doing a
summit push he was going from three to
two exactly he was descending just after
me like i had left camp just with him
before that he had he had been coming
everyone with that point is now coming
down there's a three that are still up
on the mountain but everyone else is
like it's over their summit push they've
tried they haven't you know whatever and
they're coming down now a lot of people
went but the masks failed or whatever
and now people are coming back down the
mountain
and i remember i remember just telling
myself i must have misheard that like
there's no that that didn't happen like
just a full that's i'm just in denial i
mean just in full denial retrospectively
and i get back down to camp one and i
called john on the radio and um i say to
him
um
hey i'm at camp one um i'm gonna just
send the last section to advanced base
camp and that's the section sergey had
fallen and died and he was like just be
careful but his voice was like just calm
dead calm like not alarm like if he had
known something i was like oh yeah it
must have been a mistake because like
his he's not saying anything to me like
everything's fine he was like he was
like hey man like you're probably hungry
like i'll walk out on the glacier
between advanced base camp and like
bring you like you know some warm water
and some soup or something like that
like just get down this next section by
yourself and like i'll be there to like
walk back to base camp with you
and uh
i um
i'm just standing about halfway about
around the spot actually where john had
turned around before halfway between
advanced base camp in camp one all of a
sudden i hear these helicopter rotors
i'm like helicopter that's not usually a
great time like in these mountains in
this in this moment in time and i'm
looking up i'm looking up up up i'm
looking everywhere up for a helicopter
because you look up for a helicopter
and i realized
it's nowhere to be found but i looked
then i looked down the route and there's
a helicopter hovering just off the
ground you know several hundred feet
below me and i look at there and i see a
splayed out body on the ground
just backpack sprawl to the side body on
the ground in a really unnatural
position
and i look up and i can just see where
his body has fallen from way up on the
route all the way back down um
falling from oh my god you felt the
route is so direct
that you fall from camp three around
camp three you literally end up at the
bottom of the ropes right where i'm
climbing towards and i look down a
little bit further and there's actually
his mitten is on the route right in
front of me and i pick it up
how did you not see him fall past you
then
it's just where i was on camp two
there's like some sort of like cliffs
the edges where you can't see the whole
route but then when you get back to camp
two it opens up on this big icy face
it's like it's easy for me to picture my
mind probably hard to picture it so he
was just looking at the ropes versus
looking yeah like when he came so
um
but then in that moment like it was off
it's like there's no denying this i'm
looking at a dead body on the ground
right below me where i'm climbing
towards and his mitten i had just been
with him and i was just
really breaking down um obviously it was
like i gotta get home to jenna and jack
i gotta get home to jen and jack because
this last part is super super
consequential still
and then i got myself
back down off of the ropes and i'm still
alone
and um
i recorded a little bit of this just so
i could remember this intense moment but
just a really
really big breakdown obviously for me
and just crying and i couldn't believe
it what had happened and it was horrible
and what's playing out um horrifically
on the other side of this is that john
dr john even though he's talking to me
calmly on the radio
atanos girlfriend shiny um had actually
been in base camp just like jenna she
had been in base camp with us and she
had stayed on for the entirety of the
expedition and my mind immediately went
there because i'm picturing
like
it's such a parallel experience like my
wife jenna has just been with me in base
camp yeah jenny had come to support
him yeah it makes me emotional like
really emotional because it just she was
such a beautiful supporter and he was
just so lively and funny and like
um
of course my heart just like completely
went out to her like imagining what it
would have been like for me to be there
and have the same news it's just ah
just like unimaginable and he didn't
fall trying to push to the summit it was
like okay we're pulling the plug on the
dangerous part
turning around and then you realize like
there is no
safe
and peace to any of this and john i mean
john has just been a hero in my life in
so many ways but he in this moment
experienced maybe some of the most
intense trauma that any of us experience
on this mountain even though he wasn't
on the mountain which is
he
being the only person in base camp at
this point um you know english native
english speaker at this point yeah he
hears over the radio and he's talking
with the cook staff and the liaison
officer and understanding this accident
had happened he's checking his tracker
and sees that autonomous satellite
tracker went goes from slowly going down
to like just a straight line all the way
down to the bottom of this mountain it's
like pretty clear that he's fallen
really far
and so he has to go in and tell shenny
and say
hey shani
atanas fell and he's likely dead
and so he was with her even when he was
talking about the radio he was with her
for about four hours while they're
retrieving the body
and then he makes the choice to not tell
you because he's like i just need colin
to be calm and exactly get back down
exactly and then when he and he's also
communicating with me so john is holding
this like
really intense space for these you know
partners of
collin and of course atanas who's passed
away and then
he did walk out and meet me on the
glacier
and
i just kind of fell into his arms like
crying and i'm like i'm so glad we're
both safe like
uh
you know i might kind of confuse because
he doesn't say anything i'm like you
heard about ottanos right
and he's like yes like of course i just
didn't want to tell you and he's like
and furthermore
they grabbed the body from the bottom of
the mount where i saw the helicopter
took his body and then it's really hard
to get helicopters in and out and nepal
there's more helicopters you can like
get them more easily but in pakistan
it's all controlled by the military
airspace so the helicopters will only
come in like a really
basically
every body retrieval or like a really
heightened like circumstance you can't
just be like oh tomorrow let me call a
helicopter nepal you can do that and
pakistan you can't do that yeah
and so not only did he have to tell
sheny but he actually had to get sheny
pack up all of her stuff and with
othnos's body inside of the helicopter
he had to say hey shiny i need you to
get inside of this helicopter because
otherwise you have to walk out for seven
days
man
um
just brutal and so that's the space he's
holding and it's just i mean it's so
still hard for me to talk about but
it was a huge tragedy and
that's not even the biggest tragedy of
this whole thing um which is
again
it's been a long story at this point so
i won't belabor it but
long story short
no one ever you know it's getting into
the evening the later evening and i'm
back in base camp and then three or four
hours later other people kind of start
filtering back off the mountain um
everyone's so exhausted and tired from
this push and all that stuff and
everyone's like has anyone heard from jp
has anyone heard from ali has everyone
heard from john and ollie's son is
waiting at camp three everyone's
abandoning camp three at this point are
coming down because the weather's coming
in just like expected it's the following
afternoon evening the weather's kicking
up it's getting dark again
no one's heard from them no one's heard
from them sajid this 21 year old whose
dad is like this famous world cast
climber taking him under his wing taking
his son out to these mountains hasn't
heard from him we're hearing on the
radio i'm staying here i'm waiting for
him staying here i'm waiting for him
and long story short jp ali and
john snorri never returned that night
and they also died um pushing through
this mountain bush on the summit push
and it's still their bodies were found
six months later in the summer season
um
but they're still unclear
what happened they were all spread apart
looks like they froze doesn't look like
it was a fall
unclear if they made it to the summit or
didn't make it to the summit but
the net result is
you know
15 or so people went over there to
attempt to climb k2 in winter and
five dim didn't come back um atana sergi
jp john and ali between the five of them
they had 15 kids
um
and
it's
i mean like i said it's been a year and
a half and it's still
hard to
to really fathom and really think about
the tragedy and the loss and also
there's um you know i've
done some therapy i've done some work to
kind of process a lot of this and one
thing that's
was interesting for me that was kind of
put into my mind by someone who i was
working with was
to kind of go through this i want some
visualizations back into that tent back
in that decision-making process and you
know following my intuition and all this
which certainly saved my life
was understanding the difference between
trauma and grief
i guess i've kind of put them in the
same bucket in my mind
but
fortunately um
fortunately it's not even the right word
but just the the truth of my my mental
health at this point is that the the
trauma the sort of ptsd the waking up in
the middle of the night afraid
is not prevalent in in my experience in
recovering from you know
assimilating this into my life but the
grief is immense this the i find myself
crying and deep sadness around you know
losing these incredible incredible
friends and people who i just admired
and
people who were just right there in that
moment
and then certainly replaying back
that
the the shiny moment of that with
imagining jenna being that person
imagining that being you know our story
um and how close um that could have been
but how is that not
traumatic of course it's traumatic yeah
yeah i don't especially the more that
you you know could foresee how it could
have been you and then also traumatic
for you jenna you know to be
a participant and
sort of an observer of all of this like
how does that
with a year and a half of perspective on
this like how does that shape how you
think about these things and
assess risk like do you really need to
keep doing this
you know is there is there more to be
learned from
pushing to the next peak
or is it time to assimilate what you've
already learned and you know find a
different way to
you know grow and share
yeah i mean
for me
i don't i don't know if colin's ever
showed us on the podca podcast before
but when i was 17 i lost my high school
boyfriend in a motorcycle accident
and
that was an earth-shattering experience
for me you know the person you're in
love with and yes i was young but in
love with and think you're doing life
with to just all of a sudden be ripped
from your from your life and heart is
devastating dramatic all of the hard
words
um and then to be in a relationship with
another speaker
right what's going on there yeah yeah i
mean
i i probably chose it and right my own
way
um but i think
you know more so i think colin and well
i'll say you know i compartmentalized
for sure i've definitely gotten good at
that coping mechanism call it whatever
you want um but i do think that there's
been a level of learning and trust
and talking about
intuition and gut that has certainly
begun to play more heavily in decision
making and
i also sometimes lean on
the probably wishful thinking of
that loss happened to beam once in my
life surely the universe is not going to
teach me that lesson again which i know
is a compartmentalizing
methodology right that's like uh did you
ever read the world according to garp
yeah so it's like the plane hits the
house and they're like we're good now
right nothing like that's ever gonna
happen again like i'll buy the house
right exactly yeah i mean no i mean i
will say we you know and we can talk
about this after but we we did choose
shortly after that to go
back and colin was going to kind of go
out there and climb again i had chosen
not to to climb everest but
it's a it's an interesting thing i mean
we certainly i think in this moment in
time right now today are
focused on creating a family and
thinking about some you know other goals
that we have that aren't so
risk
oriented um but yeah i mean i'd love to
hear i mean
i want to clarify i was saying about
trauma before not to say the entire
experience was deeply traumatic and
there's deep like trauma in there um
was trying to express was that
i haven't had that kind of ptsd kind of
shiver from this experience um that i
know is experienced by many people who
experience trauma in all sorts of ways
but the trauma and certainly the sadness
and the grief is you know deeply
prevalent and very much still on the
surface in my day-to-day life
um but also what jenna said is is
interesting um and uh there is a chapter
in the book about this so i'll give away
the whole story certainly and probably
not time for tell a whole nother long
story but
two months later we went back
we went to nepal um
and
posner was on that expedition what you
talked about at length on your podcast
and the frightening things we
experienced and this avalanche we all
get hit by
and i was there with jenna and jenna
made the decision to
kind of surprise the heck out of all of
us and actually
attempt to climb
everest herself and so two months later
um after this k2 experience we find
ourselves back on a mountain back at 8
000 meters back climbing and now i'm
doing so with the person that's the most
important person to me on the entire
planet which is jenna and i'll you know
let you read that in the book to get the
whole the whole story there it's a
powerful story and it's one of the most
impressive things i've experienced
alongside of jenna um and her courage
and her strength
but there's also a piece of it that's to
me about
twofold
if that experience in k2 had been my
last time climbing i think that'd be
really hard for me because i would've
been like wow i took this all the way up
to the edge and then that was it and i
just like walked away from it at that
point
do i need to go back and try to climb k2
in winter
probably not
um but i'm also glad that that's not the
last expedition i went on not the last
memory the last memory that i have is
standing on top of the world with my
wife like and having this incredibly
triumphant moment and carrying the flags
of the five guys who passed and honoring
them up there on those mountains
i think for me um
as a
sort of a
closing thought anyways on this story
people have asked me a lot like are you
afraid of dying are you afraid of dying
are you trying to die you have a death
wish like you're so a risk taker you
know whatever way someone frames that
question
and i've thought a lot about that
and i think my kind of response to that
is the last thing i want to do is die
my launcher i want to get back home to
jenna and jack hopefully soon we'll have
a family and there's jenna jack and a
little little new soul in our family and
i think that will of course have its own
lasting shift and impact and i embrace
that moment when that moment comes
um
but my biggest fear is not living right
like my biggest fear is actually not
living and i've come to think of the
world
of i think of sort of human experience
our experience in life on this scale of
one to ten ten being like the highest
highs that we experience and one being
the lowest lows
and i think too often we are often stuck
in four to six in like this zone of
comfortable complacency in this zone of
like eh like good enough right like go
to a job it's fine but i don't love it
like have this relationship with my
partner it's fine but it's not it
doesn't like light me i just like it
just stuck sort of in the middle and i
think in our modern society it's so easy
to live between four and six um it
really is like there's enough modern
conveniences that generally have a lot
of people have access to not every
person but a lot of people have access
to certain things that allow people to
be
you know as some level of comfort
um
and when i think back on my tens all of
my tents you know even from my
expeditions from my personal life from
business successes whatever
they're all built on the back of ones
like
getting the sponsorship like we talked
about at the top of this conversation
for our first expedition was such an
amazing moment when we finally broke
through and and got it not just columbia
with the other sort of businesses that
we got involved whatever but it was
because of the thousand doors that
slammed in our face like before that
right
getting to the other side of antarctica
alone
was this deeply
personal insightful journey and
ultimately a 10 when i completed this
crossing and set this record blah blah
blah
but not because there weren't so many
ones along the way and so when i think
about that i think about
like i said i'm not i'm i don't want to
die but i'm more afraid of not living
not afraid afraid of of living a life
between only four and six and do we need
to be in four and six sometimes of
course we need to recover there we need
to build from there we need to be stable
it's not like i'm just trying to have
only peak experiences on the you know
pendulum swing of life
but i do think the full tapestry of life
is a beautiful thing and even when i
think back on that k2 expedition it's
such a horrible tragedy and i
it tears me apart inside every single
day
and i also
in some strange way
i'm glad that i went on that expedition
yeah and the tens have to be earned by
the willingness to grapple with the ones
right for sure you don't get the tens
without the ones or at least accepting
the the risk or the possibility of them
right the like putting your heart and
soul into something that you deeply care
about knowing hey this might not work
this yeah i might fail with this but
like i'm out here trying right
that feels like a great place to end
this podcast and we're inching up to up
to like three hours at this point but
but
we can't just like slide over the fact
that like
jenna jennings
we had this like expansive 90-minute
story about k2 and then at the end be
like oh by the way like
like
so i have to hear about that experience
and what that was like and
if it measured up to
your expectations of of what it would be
like like my only experience of what
that might be like is from having these
types of conversations or watching
documentaries or whatever and i have an
idea
but what was the reality of like that
yeah um so a little bit of background
just to lay the foundation i like i said
before was not into mountaineering do
not really even consider myself an
athlete
certainly had not like dove into the
literature or watched all the movies or
dreamed about it as a child um and so
again it's been an interesting evolution
because i remember when colin climbed in
2016 for the explorers grand slam world
record project
i
of course was supportive of him doing it
but i was like this is crazy do you
really need to climb everest like that's
such a you know risk-taking
venture like i don't know if
you really need to do that um but then
of course i saw him be successful and
have known many friends now to have
summoned it over the years and taken
that on
and
it started to become a curiosity for me
like
am i capable can i do this is this
something that
even if it's not my big dream in the
world is it something that i could
actually
take on and overcome and so
we set out to climb from the north side
and that was very specific which is the
chinese side um i was terrified of the
kumbu ice fall which is on the south
side on the nepalese side and i was like
there is no way that i'm climbing
through the coombo i swimming calling
can attest like i just was behemothly
against climbing through the icebell it
just seemed like russian roulette
and it just wasn't of interest to me so
our planned expedition had been on the
north side from china of course in 2020
that got cancelled
then fast forward to 2021 again i had
called this off this k2 expedition
happened and i was even more like
mountains come on this is like
ridiculous why you know this is i'm not
willing to die out there i knew that in
my heart like i'm not willing to put my
life at risk
i'm out and
after k2 and colin said you know i need
to get back out there i need to do this
for my soul i said okay what do you want
to do and he had said well i would like
to go back over to everest and try this
everest lotsy double
world record project and i said okay
i'll go i'll go to base camp because i
really was interested in seeing the
culture obviously experiencing the
mountains and being over there with him
um
i don't know why coming off the k2
experience but like in my mind
in my mind i was like i think i need to
be there so um
we went and we decided and he was going
to climb from the nepalese side
obviously to do the um everest lots he
was from nepal
so we go over there
have a beautiful expedition into base
camp i mean it was just stunning um
poser's there singing with his guitar
yeah yeah she was special videos really
special and dr john was there obviously
who had just been on k2 with colin so it
kind of felt and it felt like how long
were you there like i was like how long
is how many concerts is poser playing
there like is he just living there now
yeah it was a long time there was a long
expedition and there was some really
weird weather that like slowed things
down and like it ended it's usually six
to eight weeks when i did it on the
sports grand slam was three because it
was also still an issue in the beginning
it was a long expedition
yeah it was very long um
and you know this was april through may
of that of 2021 to last year
and
um
i'm like you know getting comfortable
there like settling into base camp like
understanding what this means like
witnessing everyone's different energy
and like why they want to go and how
they want to do it and just kind of
absorbing the environment which was
really cool for me
um but again i was like i'm not planning
on climbing
especially because of the ice ball so
the kumbo ice fall base camp is nestled
basically at the foot of the kumbo as
well so it's literally the feature you
can see like right in it's like this
broken glacier with moving ice and snow
15 sherpas died in an avalanche there in
2014 there's a lot of deaths it's lower
on the mountain so people think about
the summit but it's like this really
intense
very it's when jenna says russian
roulette it's because the ice is moving
around so much that it's unpredictable
and the route breaks and moves all the
time so there literally is this
sort of feeling of like what is the
route kind of like can't control it and
the route moves and shifts and like
there's these ladders it's just it's
like a part of the feature it seems
sketchy honestly like i was always like
i don't know like i don't need to do
sketchy like i can do like clear-cut and
like push my endurance but like that
just felt like a risk i wasn't willing
to take
so then colin does a rotation up the
mountain for his project comes back
everything's great
weather comes in everyone kind of gets
grounded at base camp for a while a lot
of people are moving on the mountain
this is what early may
ish
and i was on
an adjacent mountain permit so i could
be at base camp i was on a nepsa permit
and the route
to everest and to nbc is the same up to
camp two
and i knew that but i was like again i
don't really want to climb through the
ice bowl
um but at one point colin had said to me
you know we're just having our hundredth
t in base camp and just shooting the
[ __ ]
and colin says
well why don't you just come up like in
base camp you can't actually see the
summit of everest because it's blocked
by all the mountains around us you i
mean you're like too close to the falls
right yeah but you can't actually see
the summit and colin you know i've i've
seen photos from 2016's photos and all
these stories have call and climbing
previously and colin's like why don't
you come up into the western come come
up to camp too your permit allows you to
climb to camp too
you should come and i'm like no no yeah
i don't want to do that
and over the days passing sitting there
being restless i don't know if you said
something specific but i was like
okay like okay i think i'll go and and
keep in mind i had done a trekking
expedition
to lobuche east prior to this so i had
some acclimatization obviously i'd been
living at base camp which is what 17 000
feet
and i actually felt really strong like i
never had a headache never with stomach
sick like i felt good but you weren't
training specifically for everest no
that was not
no zero like no it's kind of nuts you're
starting to think about doing this thing
that you didn't even mentally prepare to
do which
now looking back was definitely the best
way for me to do it 100
it was the incremental successes and
kind of just put the the carrot a little
further out versus saying like oh this
is this big thing for you um but colin
convinced me in some way but you were
not to be clear her permanently allowed
to go to camp two and she wasn't saying
oh now i'm gonna sum it it was like hey
let's go get you up to twenty one
thousand feet you'll experience some of
everest you'll be able to see the route
like you know this kind of stuff
um
but yeah i mean look like i wouldn't
necessarily recommend someone like climb
you know jenna's put in put had put in
the training in terms of the technical
prospection to the thing she the year
before so like that sort of stuff we had
trained her up to be prepared to climb
got canceled but then the last year the
fitness she was like i'm not training
and i mean i'll be the first one to
attest that like she didn't
train like she didn't like wasn't like
training
yeah um
and then you got up to camp two
yeah so
i
it was a tearful decision though for me
because like i had said before like i
was not
super excited about going through the
ice ball and i was honestly like afraid
like very very afraid of it and
it was one of those moments where i was
like oh this is one of these limiting
beliefs that i can choose to try to
overcome right now or i can sit in base
camp and be comfortable and see what
happens
and it really was a decision to say
let's go up there and see see what
happens
and i think i climbed faster than i've
ever climbed before because i was so
frightened going through the ice ball i
mean calling can probably a test it was
actually a pretty quick
transit from base camp up to camp one
and we did push on to camp two in a
single push which isn't common yeah it
was like
she's being very like i been around a
lot of elite athletes and all things in
my life whatever like jenna showed some
like deep like badassery strength that
was like just another level like her
times going up the mountain like through
from camp to camp like you know was on
parody if not faster than most people
who have been like training for years
for this who are like fit men like
whatever and like i have it's
interesting like having lived with jenna
over time 15 years all the things we've
done like
i've seen this side of jenna before in
these like just like kind of like random
spur like moments of just kind of like
when she fixes her mind on like
something like it's just like this like
deep like you most of the time you're
like man i'm good like whatever but then
like when it's locked in it's like this
latent
endurance
is just like right here
i can like let it out
like even postner was like me poser
trained super hard for 18 months really
crazy he's super fit whatever
and like you know there was a couple of
times when like jenna was like going
like faster times of him on certain
sections of the mountain he was like
what is like what is happening
adrenaline and fear um yeah but yeah i
mean obviously my memory anyways was i
went up higher on the mountain to a
climate has a campfire and jenna's
permit stopped at camp too so she was
there for a couple days by herself then
i came back down and i just remember
jenna just having this like look on her
eyes like
i could see the mountain for the first
time
just enchanted i was i was like oh my
god there it is like
that's like the holy grail for so many
people
and it wasn't necessarily like the
achievement that i was looking at it was
it honestly is one of the most beautiful
stunning places you will ever see it is
incredible to see the magnificence um
with your own eyes out there i mean you
are just tiny little thing
in these big huge behemoth mountains
um so good all right so i'm just trying
to understand so at some point you lock
in on this idea of trying to summit but
you got this permit problem
exactly so i have this like twinkle in
my eye at this point and
i didn't even really fully realize it
but colin is of course reflecting it
back to me as my mirror and i think i
say something like one day maybe i'll
stop at mount everest from camp two
and
because i'm thinking like i have this
permit issue obviously it's not even a
thing i haven't packed for it i again
have lost the training on it and so we
climb back down to base camp and
you could tell the pyramid story well
first of all when we were packing for
everest yeah jenna's 8 000 meter suit so
it's like a full down suit that you wear
at the summit the lower mountain you can
get away without having the full full
down suit but definitely above camp two
you need like this full suit same thing
i was wearing k2 whatever
and i had said to jenna in our garage
back home and i'm unpacking my k2 stuff
here forever so i was like well do you
want to just like bring it like just in
case like you know you know if it gets
cold or like just kind of like you know
in the back of my mind and she was just
like adamantly like why would i pack my
down suit like i'm not climbing it's not
climbing and so she left it i don't need
that because she had bought she of
course we got her all the stuff right
previous for this climb so she didn't
bring any i mean she brought the boots
and like but most of the part didn't
like have the stuff and so she's like
one day one day and i was like
one day like i don't know that like
we're coming back here like
yeah and even you were kind of like i
don't know if i'm ever coming back here
yeah want to start a family there's just
like other pieces like other priorities
and it's like but you're here and you're
like doing amazingly well i think part
of this thing is jenna's limiting
beliefs but also the power and having
proximity to something i think that
there's something that's so in life jen
and i sometimes call this life
demystified if you see like
that the story i told before you're
around all these other people that are
doing it it's suddenly that impossible
thing suddenly seems totally accessible
right yeah you know like any one of
these people on mountain ever said
anytime at their own dinner party on
their respective corners of the world or
like the person the man or woman who
like summited everest but now you're
staying there with like a couple hundred
people and john who summoned a couple of
times i have seven a couple of times
posner's there like it's like i took
posers very first mountain mount hood a
couple years before and like jenna's
watched tim train and they're really
good friends like you know it's just
like there's something that like shifts
it's like you know i actually write in
the book in a different context i write
you know hang out with five million five
millionaires you're likely to be the six
hang out with five criminals you're
likely to be the six it's sort of like
you you you are you can assimilate
i mean this is an extreme case of this
but i think you just sort of like you
were like huh
yeah like
maybe i can do this or maybe i want to
do this uh i was like enchanted i really
was i was like oh like
i'm
interested to see if there is a next
step to take here the flip side of this
of course being a terrible tragic
disaster where oh yeah something goes
horribly wrong and you're like why did i
let her go up the mountain she didn't
train for it so i mean that's you know
so i will i will so i'll say the permits
are real quick and then we'll get to the
summit push um long story short we asked
some people and in base camp can we pull
this off and like can we get a permit
and they're like they're like for next
year it was like a permit for next year
because there's like in the mountains
yeah how would that even work and it's
may 25th now because we're stuck in the
storm and it's getting late usually the
mountain is shut down by may 20 like
everyone has climbed by them but there's
this weird weather that like shuts the
mountain down for a couple weeks really
kind of un unseasonable
and we're looking at a summit date on
june for summoning everest in june is
like
almost never happened it's like
literally almost never never happened
just like way too late in the season the
lower mountain starts to melt
and sure enough i asked some some for
actually dawa the same guy who had run
some legit the logistics on k2 we had
gone and talked to him
and a couple days later we're in our
camp for base camp and there's a
helicopter landing here a helicopter
outside of our tent at six o'clock in
the morning and we hear a guy get out of
the there's a helipad like kind of near
where we are in base camp and a guy's
like miss jenna miss jenna and there's
like a nepalese voice yelling miss jenna
we like poke our head out of the side of
the tent and there's a guy carrying a
briefcase but it's got like it's like
with the tape of the ministry of tourism
of nepal
and he's like jenna's like uh i'm jenna
and he's like he unc he cuts open this
like this tape off this briefcase and
opens it and he's like
here's your everest permit
how does that happen like obviously we
had to you know pay you know a
significant amount of money whatever but
like basically
some favor not favors it wasn't like we
like broke any laws or anything like
that but just like last minute to the
right person at the right moment like
hey this person's
and they said it would here
been the last everest permit ever issued
the latest in a season ever
and we leave the next and we live or
stay issued on the mountain on the
mountain right yeah what happens if you
try to sum it without a permit oh i
think oh really really bad yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think you're like banned
from nepal for 10 years you can't come
into the other mountain it's like yeah
it's not something
um
and
anyways yeah you share your perspective
but we went we basically went back up
and as posner attested when he came here
in camp two it was a horrible horrible
incident i mean
it was
something that i had always worried
about because when you're in base camp
you hear all these avalanches falling
around you all the time and obviously
there was a devastating avalanche um
disaster in 20 what was that 15 or 16.
15 was that oh yeah 15 years and then 16
was the all the sherpa was dying in the
ice wall 14
14 and 15. sorry my dates are wrong um
and
i don't know i just like even in these
environments i'm like i don't want to
die in an avalanche i don't want to die
at all but i definitely don't want to
die in an avalanche and
it's nerve-wracking i mean you're
hearing these thunderous noises
as you're walking around out there and
you feel very small and insignificant
and
being back at camp 2 i actually felt
like i was in a comfortable position i
was like i feel good i've been here
before i'm familiar with the environment
i understand how things work at camp two
and we go to bed and it had been very
stormy i mean there was a ton of
snowfall
um
but again i was like felt like i was
like in routine at camp two and we went
to bed that night relatively early
probably like ten o'clock and
midnight rolls around and there is just
like a
what sounds like a massive freight train
barreling down and of course it happened
so quickly but
it was definitely the most frightening
experience of my life i've never been
in a situation where i actually felt
like i was going to die
this huge strong wind blew into the
valley into the western comb through our
camp through the camp next to us and it
was essentially the plume of an
avalanche and all the debris came down
and
um of course i didn't understand what
was going on at the time but it was so
cold up there i mean we were in our in
my full down suit in my sleeping bag you
know like i had probably this much of my
skin showing
um and i had tucked myself underneath um
this other layer
and it was the one time that colin and i
had gone to bed head to toe because
usually we would just sleep next to each
other normal head to head
and
this avalanche comes down this
thunderous noise and
i all of a sudden like can't really
breathe and it feels like there's an
extra layer on top of my head
and so i'm like yelling and shouting but
i can't move i'm like pinned in my
sleeping bag
and
yeah i wake up to her just screaming and
her head is
her head is in the upside mount where
the the debris and the avalanche plume
is hitting our tent and her head is like
pinned under the edge of this tent and
she's like just screaming and i sit up
and i'm like oh my god it's an avalanche
and i pull her head basically it was
kind of like
pushes the tent fabric off of me like it
pushes all the snow and whatever was on
the outside pulls me out and i am like
shaking like a leaf like i have no idea
really what's happened and colin says
it's been an avalanche and i'm was just
terrified i mean frankly
the the worst feeling you could possibly
imagine i mean when the tent was
covering my face i
i was like oh this is it this is the
thing that i didn't want to have happen
and now i'm experiencing it yeah and
postner and doctor john are in the
adjacent you know a couple tenths of
side of us and yeah i get out after that
because after passes and kind of like
regroup and talk to folks and to be
honest
i was at that moment was like pretty
like well well like we're definitely
like kind of going back down dining
tents were down this whole the camp next
to us thank god no one was there they'd
gone higher on the mountain those tents
were completely flattened like it was a
bad scene i mean it wasn't good
and
so how do you make this decision through
this so like i don't know
it doesn't make any sense rich this is
all like insane
you understand that right yes i said to
jenna so
i said in the morning i said all right
so we'll just eat some breakfast and
like we'll get out of here and i'll
never forget this comment from jenna
she's like
yeah camp two [ __ ] sucks let's get
out of here and i'm like yeah well this
eat breakfast then we'll climb back down
one more time so koombo ice fall and
we'll go home she was like down i said
camp 2 sucks let's get out of here and
go up i was like if it's safe to go up
let's go up you have to remember i'm
like replaying all the things that i
didn't want to have happen i think i'm
going to die in the kumbu ice fall i
just got hit by an avalanche like i'm
like well i guess if it's safe to climb
let's go up that seems like the for
whatever reason safest decision
and yeah i mean in the end it all ended
up working out i mean we climbed to camp
three spent a night there climbed to
camp four spent some time in the death
zone um and ultimately made a summit
push and it was
i mean
the most beautiful majestic like
insanely
rewarding thing to actually stand on the
summit of the top in the top of the
world with with i mean it was pretty
special the
you said something before which that
that definitely triggered my biggest
emotion on this entire thing which is
i have taken a lot of these risks
obviously i'm on my own and through
jenna's sort of deep support and
partnership and camaraderie but i've
been the one in harm's way for the most
part right now you're responsible for
her well-being and it's incumbent upon
you when she says what do you mean when
we're going down we're going up for you
to be like are you sure about that like
maybe that's not such a good idea and
when you get above camp four and the
deaths on the summit push essentially in
i had an experience in 2016 where i was
coming back down the mountain a woman
wasn't climbing with her but i knew had
fallen down on the ground her action
mask wasn't working and she couldn't get
up
and people had said to me up high on the
mountain you can't like pick somebody up
or carry them but i always
intellectualize that of like that seems
like an exaggeration like surely if
someone's in really bad shape you're not
gonna like let them lie on the ground
and die like you could do something i
remember in 2016 seeing this woman who
you know again acquaintance of mine
um lying on the ground and like thinking
to myself like can i pick her up right
now you know we're at south summit
twenty eight thousand seven hundred feet
or whatever it is and being like no like
i like and i got down on the ground and
i was like you gotta get up and like
talking her and like trying to get her
back up we all they got her oxygen mask
back on and she got her up moving again
but there was this moment where i was
like i can't do anything to help this
person literally me my full strength
coming down the mountain there's nothing
i can do to like i can't carry this
person back down
and so i remember feeling that feeling
and when we're leaving camp four with
jenna and like being like whoa like i
have actually been up here before and i
have just been in an environment where
people died around me on k2
and now i'm here in this situation where
it's like my role to like protect jenna
but also being like hey jenna like
up in the death zone like if something
goes wrong like obviously i'll do
everything i possibly can to make sure
to save you or whatever somewhere wrong
but like really if i'm being honest
there's not a whole lot either of us can
do to help each other if something goes
really wrong we actually have
we know a husband and wife couple where
the the woman passed away on the
mountain in 2016 um and the husbands
arrived so
i don't know man i would say
summoning mount everest with jenna was
of all my expeditions obviously there's
no world record or blah blah blah
associated with jen and i summoning i
think we're the fifth couple married
couple or something like that um
was the most beautiful incredible
experience to share in like the highest
ten of all tens you know to have that
moment together
but the vulnerability and the intensity
of holding that space for jenna
on that climb
pushed my limits beyond
what i kind of expected
and also gave me a renewed not that i
haven't had the highest level of respect
for what jenna has done for me over the
years but at even deeper reverence for
what it's like to be jenna and get the
phone call from the k210 or the
antarctica this or the text message that
says i'm alone and then have no response
and like having held that space
so often
for me and to have the
the flip side of that to be out there
with you and feel that vulnerability and
the lack of being able to control the
situation
and
yeah the stakes and not for nothing
to do it without really actually
properly training
it's a cherry on top
and without that i mean yes you had the
technical training the year prior and
had the fitness then yeah it was
surprising but to do it in
maybe whimsical is a is too strong of a
word but in a
less than entirely
way
is
impressive also perhaps a little bit uh
unhinged maybe i'm glad it all worked
out yeah and it's inspiring but i'm
pretty good here at sea level yeah and i
can get my head around the 12-hour walk
and we'll keep it at that yeah let's uh
yeah join us for the 12-hour walk on
september 10th let's get skullnick to do
it too let's get i'm sure he'll be down
with it um yeah cool so the book comes
out august book is out august 2nd 2nd um
12-hour walk and then
12hourwalk.com is where you can get
information about the
community piece yeah 12hourwalk.com come
check it out you can sign up there um
stay in touch with us we're like i said
the our next everest is to inspire 10
million people to take the 12-hour walk
so so join us join us for the walk you
can do it any day but september 10th is
going to be a big
walk alone together kind of day to be
accountable um and excited to have you
and hopefully skolnik join us right on
this adventure you can find colin at
colin o'brady on all the social stuff
and jenna how do people find you
um i'm not the best at social stuff but
at jenna b saw you throw some stuff up
there yeah
um cool all right i love you guys thank
you so much yeah pleasure thanks for
having me thank you awesome
peace
[Music]
you